starting it
i have to read the uh
an announcement
as chair of the house resources
recreation and development committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor and
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2000 dash
excuse 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee hearing
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public who
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming
that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
has the ability have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting
to be the notice of this meeting notice
complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting shall call
or email hcs.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us brad
greenland committee researcher
please note that all votes are taken
during the meeting shall be done by roll
call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
don't ask the clerk
please call the rule
thank you mr chair
um representative gunski representative
gunski is here
gunski is here representative gould
representative gould is here and alone
uh representative gold is here
representative horrigan here home alone
representative horrigan is present
representative harb
i am here present in my office and i'm
presently alone
representative harp is here
representative crichton
here in the committee room
representative creighton is president
representative dodge
president alone
representative dodge is president
representative harvey harvey bolya is
present in her office alone
representative healey
home office alone
uh representative healy is president
representative mayville representative
mayville is present and alone
representative mayville is president
representative post
representative post is present and i am
in aloft with um speak uh
um
i want to say speakers on but headphones
on excuse me and i was told by someone
the other day that um people could hear
things from below so
do you need me to move to another room
no
no okay thank you
okay um
representative post as president
representative smith
here at home and alone
okay
um representative smith is president
representative spang
unmute judith
is she
representative spang you need to unmute
representative spanx
okay i got it
am i unmuted now
i think you want your
you are unmuted
uh you want to lift the screen
okay i'm here and alone
there i am
representative spang is present
representative grassy representative
gracie is here and alone
representative gracias president
representative gottling
here alone
representative gottling is president
representative cohen i am here and alone
representative cohen is present
representative connors
i'm here and i'm in my office and i'm
alone
representative connors is present
representative vail
i'm here in my kitchen
alone
representative vale is present
representative kelly
president
uh representative kelly is present
representative moran
uh present and alone
representative ren zulu president and in
the committee here
okay that's 20 present
thank you very much
first bill that uh
what we have is
house bill
house bill 158
and the chair recognizes
representative grassy to introduce the
bill
thank you mr chairman uh for the record
my name is representative chuck grassy i
represented stratford county district 11
which is wad4 in rochester
i'm the prime sponsor of house bill 158
which is relative to the definition of
prime wetlands this bill has been before
this committee twice before it has
passed both times
uh has uh passed the senate the first
time in last session it
basically died on the floor of the
senate uh because of kovid
the first time this passed the house and
the senate went to conference committee
and the governor veto bill
i will discuss that in a little bit here
i would say that the bill that you have
before you is the bill that came out of
conference committee uh it was
negotiated uh in a bipartisan way
and also with uh the lobbyists involved
in the discussions that went on during
conference committee as well
so what you have here is a bill that is
pretty much
a very simple build
how we define prime weapons
prime wetland says
relatively this is relatively
insignificant
right now you have about 32 33
communities who have prime weapons that
they've identified in the in the state
and
we have a couple more that would like to
do this
but because of the changes that were
made back in 2012 they have uh they have
not gone forward with their prime
weapons definitions let me give you a
little bit of history prime wilkins was
basically i was originally adopted in
1990 1979 i was actually a member of the
house back then
um
in
august 24th of 007
there was a 100-foot buffer
that was added to the bill which
required there to be a 100-foot setback
from any prime weapons in 2009
um it was also required that any
activity within the prime weapons or
within 100 foot buffer communities would
have to be noticed
prior to any work being done and they
were given a 20-day window basically to
look at what went on in the prime
weapons
in august of 2012
the 100-foot buffer
and this 50-foot width was repealed
prior to 2012 this 50-foot width existed
in the regulations
the re the rules as they currently state
and the way the legislation was written
back in 2012
said that any parcels approved between
the dates of 2009 and 2012 would
continue to have that hundred foot
buffer
which is quite unusual usually if we
take something away we would take it
away from everybody but in this case any
of those towns that approved it it would
have 100 foot buffer and they would also
include the areas that had 50 foot width
requirement but this is going to say
what the bill does is
is basically says currently if you have
areas that are less than 50 foot wide
and we have other people
rick van de polis here who will be able
to explain that a little bit more the
geometry around it a little bit more
than i can but
what it did was is
prior to 2012
those areas could be included as long as
they met the requirements of the
legislation there are some details that
i'll i'll get into in just a minute
after 2012 it took out those smaller
areas they may be just as important but
it did not provide protection for those
things
you're going to see maps
in fact we all received in the mail map
show two weapons and a long skinny line
between them
this
i mean yeah it may be that this long
skinny line maybe a stream it may be a
weapon
it's less than 50 foot wide
and the opponents to the bill are saying
that
this is
a problem that they can't have this
could be a mile long that's relevant
well there's not a lot of sense to this
in order to be a prime woman there are
12 requirements
that they have to look you have to meet
four of 12 requirements one
that it might that has to be
a wildlife habitat
it must be dependent on a wildlife
habitat
and then there are 11 other criteria
that it has to meet as well one is
ecological integrity
possibly efficient aquatic life habitat
is this a good fishing area as well
scenic quality of that of that wetland
educational potential
wetlands-based recreation we're going to
be dealing with some of that in the hoyt
pawn
bill that's coming up later
blood storage this is something that's
very important for a lot of communities
and some of the communities that are
looking at doing this in the future
they're looking at it a lot a lot of
what they have is it has the wildlife
habitat and it also is something that's
very important for flood storage and
that's very costly for both the state
and the local communities groundwater
recharge and the purification of
groundwater this is something that's
very very important for communities as
well when we're looking at efas and
other types of contaminants in our
groundwater wetlands have been found to
be the most successful way to treat the
eminence before it gets into the
groundwater and our drinking water
supplies
sediment trapping
nutrient trapping retention and
transformation this is something that's
very valuable in the coastal community
as well with
nutrient trappings before it gets into
the
coastal areas and any rivers as well i
know here in rochester we have problems
with with nutrients in our in our
wastewater
in the river out from the wastewater
well a lot of this stuff is coming
upstream downriver
wetlands are able to help purify that
also shoreline anchoring and
noteworthiness i'm not sure exactly what
noteworthiness means but pes put that in
there and they obviously know what it
means when they take over when you take
a look at a wetland must have four of
those criteria
my life plus three additional now
under this bill
when you add
something that's less than 50 feet
you must consider it separately you must
consider that that 50-foot piece that
small piece has to have these same
requirements
so something that's a mile long or a
half mile long or even a football field
long
probably quite unusual that in the
middle of that it would meet these
requirements
so if you just use a little bit of
common sense
the chance of something that's less than
50 feet wide
is probably not going to meet the
criteria
for a
prime weapon
therefore it wouldn't be included
something else that we have that
to just address the governor's veto for
just a second
one of the things when the governor
vetoed this bill afterward went through
the house was passed by the senate
accepted by a conference committee he
said that he
he opposed it because it did not give
enough consideration
to the landowners the people whose land
was going to be impacted
first of all
slave
consideration
acceleration or consideration the
landlord landowners so basically the
governor saying he's opposed to the
current law as it states
i understand that
unfortunately it's the law
if you want to change that
repeal it
what this bill actually does though
is it gives extra consideration
to the landowners because when a
landowner
land is being impacted or being
determined to be within that prime
wetland area that's less than 50 feet
wide and this only deals with less than
50 foot wide areas
the landlord the the landowner must be
considered the impacts on that land
owner must be considered
in order to be a prime wetland a
conservation commission a planning board
a local governing body needs to take a
look at what they feel is an important
prime weapon in their town as i said
about 32 33 communities have adopted
there's only a handful
that are looking to adopt this and i
don't see a big outpouring i mean since
nobody has applied for a prime weapon
i don't see this as being something
that's going to be big but
they have to go to get it approved as a
prime well and they have to go through
the same process as
they would for a zoning ordinance
all of you in town know that a zoning
ordinance or the planning board it needs
to go to public as that public parents
it also has to have a wetland scientist
do a study on that prime wetland to
determine its importance and to validate
that it meets four of the 12 criteria
that are required to be designated as a
prime weapon
when we asked for the lesser land area
we also go negotiated some gift facts
basically
one was that the landowner needs to be
considered
and two
we put an exemption in for dot
right now if you're in a community where
you have flooding and it's got a prime
wetland in it
you've got to wait
20 days for the state to review this and
then for the for the state review within
20 additional days for the local
community to before you can go in and
you can work
to basically make improvements if a road
gets washed out
our exemption not only applies to these
small areas but also applies to
prime wetlands in general
so that if there is a problem an
emergency this will save a lot of time
and also money
for d.o.t to go in and do road
improvements this is what surprised me
the most when the governor you know the
original this was in there
and and having been a town planner and
also a city councilman i understand here
in rochester i understand the importance
of being able to get in there and get
the work done quickly
particularly if it's it's a major road
that's been washed out or impacted by
flooding or other damage that working
with a prime wetland is something that
we have to trust d.o.t to go in there
and do a good job now i know some of the
conservation groups are opposed to that
portion of it don't have that taken out
but as someone who has worked on both
sides of the issue i felt it was
important to protect dot's interest when
it came to prime wetland as well as
letting the local communities
designate prime wetlands protect their
natural resources protect their
groundwater protect wildlife habitat in
their communities
mr chairman you're going to have other
people that are going to be speaking i
know we've got one letter that says if
this bill passed it's going to land lock
pieces of land this is just not true the
current law as it states and those 32
communities
if they have problem with the bill they
have it as it as the law currently is
this bill does nothing to change that
and no communities are going to be no
land is going to be landlocked
in nowhere does it say in the prime
wetlands organize the primary wetlands
rsas or the regulations that were
adopted to prove it that you can't
develop a prime weapon
you just have to go through more
consideration and there's a when it's
considered a prime wetland within that
community you can do all the development
you want if you can get approval virgin
fir dredge and fill permits may take a
little longer but only in those areas
that are determined to be prime weapons
what we
a prime wetland
under the current regulation where it is
needs to be a
geometric shape
near the debates we've had about this
myself and the chairman in particular we
talked about the fingers and toes
wetlands are not
perfect geometric shapes
they have rills they have ditch client
pitches they have other things one of
the other things we put in the bill that
i didn't mention as well is that we also
added a provision that say no man-made
structures would be able to be
considered as prime wetlands
so we've taken out man-made structures
we've added the provision that
landowners need to be considered we've
added a provision for dot for a waiver
for dot
all we're asking is that you allow the
prime wetland to be defined the way it
naturally exists it has those fingers
and toes
i'll rest here and uh i'm sure that
you'll have other people and i know mr
van pold is here today to speak on that
bill
speak on the bill as well thank you mr
chairman i'll be happy to answer any
question oh representative gracie do you
have uh
uh
you have your your comments do you have
any uh written
testimony or uh
i i do not have anything written down i
just have notes mr chairman i can
certainly send you i can
take shots of the data that i use the
pages that i use for my information and
share them with the committee after the
meeting
whatever whatever you feel is necessary
thank you thank you
all right
uh
the members of the committee have a
question of representative gracie
representative creighton
uh thank you for a question uh mr
chairman
uh representative grassy uh
great testimony i and i understand the
importance of protecting the wetlands
but but this 50 feet is actually 250
feet if you have a 100 foot setback is
that correct
that's that's the thing the 100 foot
setback was taken out in 2012 it does
not exist
so
the the the problem is
is that under current
law
those wetlands that were approved
between 2009 and 2012
do have the 50 foot
they are mapped out at 50 feet and they
have the 100 foot buffer so under the
current law
not what i'm proposing here but the
current law yes you are correct it could
be 250 feet that's current law that has
nothing to do with this bill and this
bill won't paint that
what this bill does is it says that we
want work within that 50-foot area and
only the 50-foot area not the buffer
because it there is no buffer it was
taken out in 2012.
we're not asking if the buffer be put
back
just that 50-foot area is the area the
land that we want additional
consideration taken when reviewed by
when reviewed by des and when the local
planning board takes a look at what the
work that they're doing within that
wetland
okay thank you for a follow-up sir
for a follow-up yeah and okay thank you
for for that answer and that
clarification
um the other question is as a landowner
in a wetlands i'm very familiar with
this process
if this bill passed
um
then and let's say i as a landowner had
a 50-foot
piece that was
uh in
prime wetlands
then not only would i have to go to the
local guys for approval within the local
ones but then for the prime wetlands i
would now be required to go to the state
at the state zoning
hearing which you
which you mentioned then the state would
then
apply
or be able to apply four of the 12
requirements
in addition to the local requirements of
the local weapons
and so what i don't understand is how
this then adds additional onus on the
owner to go to the state
as well as whatever local ordinances
they would be required
right did i miss something on that i'm
sorry i'm i'm new at this
that's all right representative no it's
it's it's not as complicated as that
first of all if you're going to be doing
work in a woman's period you're going to
have to get a dredge and fill permit
and when you go to get that dredge and
full permit or a weapon crossing
whatever it may be the state's going to
take a look at it anyway now those 12
criteria that you have they're not
something that's applied by the state
applied prior to the designation of a
crime wetland
a prime weapon
becomes a prime well because it meets
for these 12 requirements
the state is just going to say okay if
the town has determined that it meets
the requirements we've approved it
because
out of the process the state also has
taken and approve it as a private
wetland as well to make a double check
the pound before the designation is made
they're going to take a look at it and
they're going to basically say okay
we're looking at your dredging field
permit or your weapons crossing or
whatever you're planning on doing within
this prime weapon
we will now notify the local community
that you've applied for a crossing
pricing the town may not even know that
you're doing this in fact
uh but you've applied to the state for a
permit to cross a weapon to impact the
weapon
they're going to
notify the local community
that you applied and they will have the
local community of 20 days to respond if
they don't respond because they feel not
an issue they've gone out looked at it
they've said they've probably said your
local neighbors have probably sat down
with you and said hey what are you doing
and you say well i'm just putting this
crossing so i can timber that site
um on the other side of the small
wetland that i have
and they may look at and they say not a
problem now that small wetland isn't
going to be just a small wetland itself
it's it's attached to a larger wetland
which has to be over two acres
so uh it's it's part of a larger wetland
as well if it isn't part of that larger
wetland it can't be considered
as a prime wetland so you wouldn't have
you'd still have to get a violence
crossing
um and and that's the only time you'd
apply to the state for it
having worked as a town planner uh
sometimes i would only find out that
there was work being done out in the
woods that a wetland crossing was
happening was i got a call from the
state
and the state would say hey you've got
somebody out there do you have any
comments you'd like to make because it
was a piece of land that qualified under
this requirement um
the
just the wetlands not even a prime
weapons i have never worked in a
community that had crime watkins
designations but i have had communities
that have wetlands sometimes the state
would call us and say you know we're
doing this as a courtesy for you go out
and take a look at what's going on
because we don't have time to go out and
look at this
but no i don't see it as something that
as you as an owner of the land are going
to be
this is not something that's going to
cause you any
great hardship it may be a sliding
convenience but not a great hatred
that's actually the current law that's
not this bill it's the current law
okay thank you representative i
appreciate that clarification
any other questions from members of the
committee
so i see no hands raised so you know
hands thanks very much for your
testimony
thank you
uh the chair will recognize
another
committee member
to speak
representative spain
thank you i don't need to speak i think
that uh representative grassy said
everything
all right representative spang declines
to
speak
all right
i'll uh
the chair will recognize
gary abbott
speak in opposition okay do you want to
give him a um
uh
the uh
no i just go right into it
uh thank you very much chairman uh for
the record uh my name is gary abbott i'm
the executive vice president of the
associated general contractors and happy
to be here today uh before your
committee to talk about house bill 158
one the association strongly opposes
this bill and one of the things you're
going to find is
i think representative grassy did a
great job of explaining the functions of
a wetland
but wetlands are wetlands whether big or
small
and those areas in which are smaller are
still regulated by the department of
environmental services
over the years since 2012 it's clear
that the department has put in
additional rules
and made it much much more difficult for
developers uh people doing construction
on projects that have
definitely you have to do an awful lot
or mitigate in order to get a permit
this bill
sets us back to prior to 2012.
we had issues and we corrected those
issues with the legislature back in 2012
by setting in place this 50-foot
limitation for this higher category
prime wetlands
prime wetlands are those
that are designated by the town
they're just as valuable in some cases
as regular wetlands and we have wetland
regulations but what was happening is
we were getting inconsistent
delineations of where those boundaries
were
and even in some cases roadside ditches
and other things were included which
would land lock an awful lot of
properties
the legislature looked at those cases
and made the determination that if we
were going to do prime wetlands it's two
prime wetlands that received the larger
wetlands
it's to save two acres or more that are
prime wetlands not the really tiny ones
it was put in place to signify that
those were uh the town had signified
them as special now some towns had
signified
uh town of salem had signified some
large acreage as prime wetlands
and then they had to widen their road
and guess what they undesignated the
prime wetlands because of the conflicts
they had in order to do that
so those are some of the things we saw
in the past 2012
corrected this by putting in that
50-foot delineation of anything that's
less than 50 feet couldn't be qualified
as prime wetlands
and it's worked great
for all these years in the sense that
delineations are very clear now
you could probably have wetland
scientists talk on either side of how
important it is to go beyond or less the
problem is is that it becomes subjective
and it gets difficult for an applicant
to know what those boundaries are
because there are tougher regulations if
you go through des
and you hit a prime wetlands it
classifies you as a special resource
area
in the rules which you have to go to a
different standard and much harder to
develop
so i did include a position paper i also
included a map
that
we presented last time this bill was
before the senate
to give you a significance of
how the area of where a prime wetland is
currently delineated and if you let that
area be less than 50 feet
a small portion could suddenly
encompasses a whole bunch of smaller
ones and i don't think that was the
original intent
of prime wetlands so we look at this
bill as a huge expansion of the prime
wetlands statute
which would affect a lot of developable
property and i represent contractors in
the state of new hampshire i represent
commercial and industrial contractors
so hopefully you've got a chance to look
at that map because i think
that's where our opposition comes from
is it makes a major expansion
the other part is in the bill
there's a lot of discussion that has to
meet four criteria out of 12.
i would tell you if you really studied
the 12 criteria it's very easy to meet
the four the four you know uh even that
last one that the representative
mentioned uh four is not difficult so
that section really it it doesn't
but it's really the the line 10 through
16 that removes that 50 foot width
is very problematic for us
just
as you take testimony today i want you
to
recognize the number of organizations
like us and other organizations
that have to go through the permit
process that oppose this bill
i think over the years every time this
bill has come up
those of us that have to go through this
process recognizes the difficulties and
have worked with the solutions in the
past
we we don't want to reverse what we
fixed in 2012.
so i just want you to recognize all the
organizations that represent groups and
the others now the the map clearly shows
it would impact uh current landowners
in the sense that new delineations and
new uh towns could map out additional
area if this bill were to pass
and i agree with the governor
[Music]
consider a property rights is much
different than having the property
owner's approval
we were involved in some discussions and
that's probably a reference that uh the
sponsor that this bill
uh one of the things we thought is
if you're ever going to do this you need
landowner
approval not considered uh considered
means he's got to fight uh the town if
they want to move in this direction
this bill just
it is really
i haven't had any great examples of the
reason to do this
because i believe
that des under its current regulations
already protects wetlands
we already have statutes that protect
the wetlands
whether big or small
and i think that's adequate and we
really haven't had the issue this is
really about a fight of adding
additional layer of regulation on
smaller pieces and uh
we definitely oppose this bill i want to
thank the chairman and the committee
members for taking the time today
to listen to me and i'll answer any
questions
any questions of mr abbott by members of
the committee
sure i see no questions
uh
thank you very much for your thank you
thank you chairman
i'm going to try to go
post and support
kevin and i uh kevin nyan
from the department of transportation
support
testifying and support
mr nyan are you there
mr diane
he's up
do you hear me
yes sir can you hear me
uh we can now
okay good uh the florida stars
you don't you know you know the drill
yes sir thank you uh
thank you mr chairman and um members of
the committee for the record kevin nyan
and i manage the environmental office
here at dot
i guess first and foremost i'd like to
thank representative grassy for
acknowledging the challenges that the
department faces
and working with us to incorporate that
second part of the the language of the
bill um it's very much appreciated and
that's really what i'm going to speak to
today
is not the definition of prime wetlands
um leave that for for other scholars but
to speak towards the uh the exemption
for the department of transportation
the bill recognizes that
our mission is to maintain the the state
highway system
and that
prime wetlands when they are lo promons
and their buffers when they're located
within the existing right-of-way
to include things like drainage ditches
drainage ditches similar areas
current law allows maintenance of these
ditches without the need for a permit
from the department of environmental
services
when we're we're cleaning them out for
example
the prime wetland designation is an
option at the local level and once
designated
applies also to state agencies
in many cases the highways existed prior
to the prime wetland designations that
the communities have made
when when located within the
right-of-way
maintenance can be unduly impacted by
the prime wetland designation as well as
the buffer
for example i think representative
grassy pointed this out as well that
when fixing a pipe for example or adding
a shoulder replacing a guard rail
it may require
additional justification or mitigation
etc when the work is located within the
boundary of the buffer or prime wetland
those
those maintenance activities if they do
impact wetlands already as has been
pointed out before there are existing
statutes and rules that that
that tell us we have to get permits
but the the buffer especially is
something that does add a bit more uh
is a bit more onerous for the department
especially when
um simply maintaining what's already
there so
um
i guess lastly in finalizing that it's
my understanding that the dot
would not have to require
be required to adhere to these
additional requirements within the
existing
uh right of way for with existing
designated prime wetlands so i just like
to make sure that i i raise that as well
so
that's all i have and i'm happy to
answer any questions that you might have
any questions but members of the
committee
sir i see no questions
uh there being no questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
uh let's say you're going to go to
a member of the member of the public
harold cook in
opposition
mr cook
is he there yes sir he's any at
mr cook could you unmute yourself and
turn on the video if he's got it and you
have video please turn it on
doesn't seem to be working
he was just there sir huh
mr chairman
mr cook no i'm sorry this is uh uh kevin
9 from the dot again i just would like
to
to say that when i did
um when i was authorized to join the
meeting it did take a second or two for
it looked like the system turned off and
on so there may be a delay just uh just
so you know that's promoting him to
panelists okay yeah we have to i guess
promoted to panelists
to be able to see him so cook was on and
now he's gone i don't know
mr cook
if that'll we'll i'll go on and we'll
try to get
you there stand by once again
so can we come back to him
we can see him he needs to unmute
no there he is he's back i got him is he
there it's the club he's on the inside
you're on new
mr cook
you're on mute
going once
going twice
okay
uh yes we can
okay oddly and
uh you're launching we're launching a
ship here this is the first time i've
done this
harold cook can you hear me okay now can
you get closer to this to your
microphone
keep talking so we can hear you okay
can you hear me
okay now
okay folks how is it
yes
continue okay my name is harold cook i'm
going to have to read this because quite
honestly
i'm a little older than some of you and
my hard drive's full believe it or not
okay speak as long as you can
my name is harold cook i live in
tamworth i'm a graduate of the
university of new hampshire in forest
resources
i would like to thank everyone for
giving me the chance to speak to the
issue of house bill
158 regarding prime wetlands
i have been a land owner for over 50
years
my work consists mostly of working with
private land owners managing the
timberland for a whole host
of reasons some of which include
the production of
timber
recreation wildlife
and sometimes just passive enjoyment
which we can all understand in these
days i'm sure
over the years we have managed several
hundred thousand acres
from one end of the state to the other
as well as land in other northeastern
states
prime wetlands is a dramatic word that
implies that our wetlands are not being
protected if house bill 158 passes will
have a devastating effect
on the forest industry in new hampshire
the quilted patent of environmental
regulations protecting our land water in
the overall forest and has been
more than adequate to protect our
natural resources and all the components
that make it viable economic resource
to file an application on the prime
wetlands
requires a public hearing
in multiple hoops through which multiple
organizations and individuals local and
otherwise
uh
the prime wetlands uh is a complicated
already and working process and
duplicates effort as it applies to
managing timberlands
quite honestly
the initial thought that i had when i
saw this come up
a while back
is that just another name
for eminent domain in the taking of land
and quite honestly i would like to say i
just hope
that you oppose this bill it is
unnecessary
and i would like to show you one thing
that the forest community
lives by on a daily basis
it's good forestry in the granite state
which is a recent publication within the
last few years
and it covers just about all of our
wetlands in timberland in the state of
new hampshire
thank you that's all i have to say
thank you very much is there any any uh
any member of the committee have a
question
for mr cook
sir i see no questions there being no
questions thank you very much for your
testimony welcome thank you
i think uh uh i'm trying my hope
going back we're trying to go
uh
for and against
so i will recognize
barbara richter representing the
new hampshire association of
conservation commissions
to speak and support
barbara richter yes hello thank you
for um
you know
opportunity to testify my name is
barbara richter i'm the executive
director of the new hampshire
association of conservation commissions
for those of you don't know the new
hampshire association of conservation
commissions is a non-profit organization
that serves
our 217 conservation commissions here in
new hampshire
the nhacc board of directors supports
house bill 158 to further define the
prime wetlands to include these narrow
narrow fingers
when they provide a
significant contribution to the prime
wetlands
um
i just want to point out that this is a
voluntary program
and currently we have about 33 towns
that do this so it's not
going to cover the entire state we're
not blanketing the entire state with um
these small fingers of wetlands to be
included it's it's a very rigorous
process to go through
and i can give you that quick background
although
representative grassy did a good job but
it's under rsa 482 conservation
commissions may select areas to
designate as prime wetlands
um and they prime what prime wetlands
are selected
because they are they have significant
value and functions um because of their
size unspoiled character fragile
condition or other factors that make
them significant so we're not talking
you know the ditches and and other areas
that don't have those that don't meet
the criteria
this is a very thoughtful process it
involves the whole community as we
talked about
a report is prepared by a professional
certified wetland scientist
and it involves careful review with both
conservation commissions as well as
other town boards and it also involves a
public hearing and town vote so it's not
an easy process and again if it were so
easy we'd certainly have more than the
33 towns that currently do have prime
wetlands and i know of many towns that
would like to have the opportunity to
have these fingers included and they're
kind of holding off right now
in in applying for this designation
until they can
include some of these really special
unique areas
um again it's des that does the final
designation of those wetlands so it's
review on the local level and review on
the state level
so
the
one of the
things that we've talked about is prime
wetland designation allows for more
local control
and a more complete review
than
when you are dealing with a dredge and
fill permit on the state level and again
it does slow things down a bit but this
is an area where we believe you should
have a more thorough um
and transparent review
so that municipalities can really ensure
that there these are the um
it's at the best level of protection for
these wetlands
so i'm going to skip skip through a bit
because a lot of testimony has already
been given but
prime wetlands
have high functions and values which is
again why they are carefully regulated
wetlands provide critical functions
including flood control groundwater
recharge water quality maintenance
through pollution filtration wildlife
habitat
shoreland stabilization and these are
all things that are really important as
new hampshire continues to grow
and more and more development is is
coming to new hampshire
and it's important to also note that
often these highest values lie in these
poorly drained areas where the narrow
fingers go stretch out into the
landscape
um
the existing law does not take into
account these wetlands that are less
than 50 feet
and it cuts off the wetland complex
and we've certainly found that
keeping the wetland as a whole is one of
the best ways to protect
the overall water resources
and
house bill 158 would further define law
to include these narrow portions and
again it's only if the municipality can
demonstrate that such narrower portions
provide a significant contribution to
the primary wetlands functions of the
prime wetlands so again it's not just
every finger and toe out there they
really have to demonstrate their
significance
so again this change would really um
allow for wetland protections on a
larger wetland complex and that better
protects our water resources
these functions and values provide a
multitude of public benefits so i think
that's something it's tough to balance
your private benefit and your public
benefit
but
again water quality
shore stabilization pollution filtration
are all really really important public
benefits that need to be considered
and
these wetlands perform their critical
functions best when they're connected
across the landscape so providing these
fingers and toes will really enhance
those values
um
though impacts to a wetland um complex
they're felt downstream and so if you
are impacting some of these upland
fingers and toes it's going to affect
the overall function of that ecosystem
and one thing one quick note to think
about
with climate change looming and on
everybody's minds these days new
hampshire is going to be one of those
areas where people will migrate to
because our climate
and we will be um
you know will be affected less perhaps
and we have water resources
so
there will be a lot of development
pressure coming in the future
so it's important to really carefully
review
our natural resources like our wetlands
before they're built and this would
provide that opportunity and again it's
a voluntary thing the towns need to
instigate this the towns need to prove
and demonstrate that they're prime
wetlands so it's not going to be every
single wetland out there so again please
help conservation commissions continue
to protect new hampshire's natural
resources and our water resources
please vote yes on house bill 158 to
allow for these narrow portions to be
included in the definition of prime
wetlands so thank you very much for this
opportunity and i'm happy to answer any
questions you may have
again is there any questions from the
members of the committee
sir i see no questions if not thank you
very much for your testimony
uh
i'm going to start holding now to the
time
limitations
and people put three minutes down i
expect
that three
year or two
jason stock
in opposition representing the
new hampshire timberland owners
association
[Music]
mr stock
to speak in opposition
yeah if he's there sir he's just gonna
arm you you have to unmute mr stop
okay
can you can you hear me near you we
can't see you okay yeah that was strange
when you announced it
there you go now you get to see my messy
office too
when you announced me
the k the uh
it was like the connection was lost that
was odd i think what he's doing he's
promoting you to a uh to a participant
okay all right well
i
like some of the other folks i i'm still
adjusting to
life with with zoom but
um i'll be quick uh again
for the record my name's jason stock i'm
the executive director of the new
hampshire timberland owners association
our members own and manage over a
million acres in the state of new
hampshire
as you heard from harold cook earlier
they managed for a host of reasons
timber
wildlife
recreation um
we're i'm here to voice our opposition
to house bill 158
prime wetlands
you know it's
crime wetlands
in those 33 communities where there are
prime wetlands if you're doing forestry
in or around them
they can significantly hinder and in
some cases
create enough of a barrier that entire
timber sales get shelved
just because there is
you know it was it was characterized as
well it's it's a little more extra work
it's a little bit of extra paperwork
well you know
in the forestry world the additional
requirements that come with a prime
wetlands managing in and around the
prime wetlands even if you're going to
use the waiver process
they are significant enough that they
can um
they can scuttle a a timber sale
um
and you know
the we already have a permitting process
in place most of the forestry permits go
through a notification process
if there's a prime wetland associated
with a particular timber sale
that kicks that permit up to a standard
dredge and fill permit
and
you know right now
that takes it to another level that just
is not economically tenable for a for a
forestry project
and again even if there is a waiver
being sought
there is still opportunity for
conservation commissions
and others to comment and modify your
your permit or your your forester's
project even the the harvesting itself
critique that
there's also a requirement for a butter
notification
and notifying the butters again this and
if you think of a finger or toe as we've
talked about i mean some of these prime
wetlands
um include water bodies such as the bear
camp river
that you can start to see where you can
get into a lot of a butter notification
in and adjacent to these bodies of water
and sending sending a certified letters
and ensuring that those abutters get
notified that is a significant not only
cost but but time
um
so again you know 158 i i appreciate the
sponsors attempt to try to put some
but
really this this bill expands
you know ex as you've heard expands the
universe of wetlands that would be
eligible to include these fingers and
toes
and by doing that um you know will it
will negatively impact forestry and
forest management
um
the the last two things i wanted to
touch on is
you know again the the consideration
the effects on landowners
i appreciate that i'm not quite sure
what consideration means
um you know mr abbott had mentioned
requiring landowner approval and we
would say that was that is much more
that is much more
would be much more appropriate
so
um again for the sake of brevity and to
keep within my my allocated timeline
slot i would just like to say that you
know this is for a landowner who has
these
wetlands on their property this is for
them it is not voluntary compliance is
not voluntary and the cost and
administrative burden that comes with
compliance for something as simple as
doing a forest forestry project
is significant enough that it is it is
it is a problem in those 33 communities
so with that i'll i'll conclude my
testimony i'd be happy to answer any
questions
any questions i'm sure we have one
question stand on
representative kelly
uh representative kelly uh
our question
yes thank you mr chairman uh thank you
for being here mr stock um just a
question did you um do you have any
sense of uh what percentage
of the toa members live in the 33
communities with prime wetland
designations
we we have we have thank you for the
question we have members across the
state
um and so i have not done i have not
done
dove into our our membership roles
um to see what towns we have members in
what i can tell you is when i look at
timber tax data and where from the
department of revenue administration
almost every town in the state on an
annual basis sees a timber harvest
so having said that each one of those
towns
i am i can speak with a degree of
certainty each one of those towns with a
with designated prime wetlands will have
some forestry timber management it may
not be a toa landowner member it may be
a nhgoa logger
forester or an nhtoa sawmill that's
trying to purchase logs
from that particular parcel that that
would be affected so
as an association we represent the
entire food chain
so
we this affects us on many parts of our
supply chain in many parts of the
industry
okay thank you
you're welcome
any other questions by members of the
committee
sir representative spang
uh representative spang uh you have a
question
yes i do
can you hear me yeah
um
mr stock can you tell me uh what are
currently the
uh
the
the areas where the uh or the
exemptions that foresters have
from
wetland regulations
it seemed i i was under the impression
that they are exempt from almost all
wetland regulations
thank you for your question we are not
exempt
um
and and if you'd like to introduce a
bill to do that
i'd be happy to talk with you about that
we are not exempt from from dredge and
phil permits in fact
anytime
anytime a a forestry operation occurs on
a piece of property and there are
wetlands present
you we have to obtain a
and there's going to be an impact i
should say so if you're cutting a 50
acre lot there's wetlands on the back
three acres and you're not going near it
obviously you would not file
not file any permits for that
but if you're going to cross a stream
or if you're going to um
primarily stream stream crossings or if
there's areas where there are
depressions a a defined channel we have
to obtain a permit from the department
of environmental services
and in those instances we have it's a
spn a statutory permit by notification
we have to obtain
it's a form we complete we do a natural
heritage check on the property
we have to
abide by best management practices
and
have to basically the landowner and the
the logger or forester sign sign that
verifying that best management practices
are being followed a natural heritage
check was obtained and conducted on the
property
the instances
where you where
a permit is not required and this is a
a piece of paper but we have to is if we
are operating on frozen ground today is
a great example
frozen ground where there is no
no rutting or any type of impact at all
if you're in a forested wetland and
there's no impact because it's frozen
or it's dry enough
at that point we have it's basically a
permit by rule
and we can operate in those instances
and not have to obtain a permit
other strategies and management
practices that get used as use of
corduroy or brush in
in travel ways or skid trails
to create a
i guess a kind of a a mattress or pillow
in which you operate on in those
instances
you can operate if you're not creating
ruts if you're not creating
any type of alteration of that
topography
you basically have a permit by permit by
rule but we do the wetland rules do
apply to us
we do um and des and the forest rangers
to the division of forests and lands
do inspect jobs they inspect jobs
against the the stand the wetlands law
and the wetlands rules
and if someone is violating that there
are tickets issued so
the rules do apply and we do obtain
permits
for a follow-up one
but isn't the permit by notification a
significantly easier thing to do than
say what a developer would have to do to
put in a house
absolutely and and i think that's wisely
i think that there's a reason behind
that um
forestry is a transient activity you're
not going to have a long-term permanent
impact
um like you would with an ass you know
impervious surfaces
um
you know and
quite frankly i think the state of new
hampshire through its policies has
recognized over the years that forestry
and forest management are desirable land
uses and that we do not want to
want to hinder those we want to in fact
encourage good forestry and good
management for all the reasons you've
heard earlier
so the permit application
is a notification process
part of that reason that it is a
notification is so that it can move
you can move quickly
and
there's an assurance that there are
rules and going to be followed but again
in in forestry because we are a weather
dependent dependent uh industry there
are instances where i may be operating
on the spang tree farm
and all of a sudden
um
the ground you know it's we get a nice
january february thought and i say all
right
representative spang we can't we can't
operate here the ground is starting to
thaw we're going to have to move our
operation we're going to go
we're going to go up to uh we have
another lot up in madbury let's do that
all right to get that permit in place to
go through a
you know a multi-month
multi-week process to obtain a permit
i do i lose that flexibility to move
we had heard with the prime wetlands you
have 14 days then there's an additional
20 days and a a public hearing can be
sought as well so you start adding that
up
you start looking at a month
almost a month's time
to obtain a permit
to say
in this instance if i have to move my
operation to to drier ground and i have
to
do a brook crossing well
if that brook happens to be
a prime wetland
that can that can that will affect my
operation and my ability to keep my crew
busy
and keep my my operation only
i wondered where you had gone with your
equipment last last spring that's right
thank you for your contribution to the
forest products industry
representative through the questions
come through the chair
thank you very much for your testimony
you're welcome
no further questions here okay mr chair
i'd like to go on thank you
this uh is let's see i'm going to call
i think uh
i see i i
see there rick der pall
uh are you there
rick van der pall
is he not there he's there he's aren't
you you have to mute
uh
identify yourself where you're from
who you represent and uh
how uh how long you are you're planning
to speak
thank you mr chair my name is rick
vandepole i'm a certified wetland
scientist i live in sandwich new
hampshire and i am alone
i will summarize my comments to for the
sake of brevity
but as many of you know
i have been behind this prime wetlands
initiative
um actually ever since it started
i was not there unfortunately in 1979
but
has have been a wetland scientist since
i helped found the new hampshire
association of natural resource
scientists i served in the new hampshire
joint board for 10 years as chair chair
and i regularly permit
wetlands that involve prime wetlands as
well
across the state of new hampshire
i have six points that again i will
summarize
point one being that we've already
passed this bill
and in fact we went through a rather
rigorous process as representative
grassy indicated
to make sure that we had found a
compromised solution
because as it stands now in 2012
the prime wetlands
component of rsa42a
has been shut down and it will still
be shut down if we don't pass a bill
similar to this
for the very simple reason that it's not
just the ditches
it is every single point
that is less than 50 feet wide has to be
clipped off
of a wetland that is being designated as
prime
and if you think about this one of the
biggest
concerns that the new hampshire
association of natural resource
scientists had back when we talked about
only having very poorly drained soils as
prime wetlands is that nobody is going
to be able to go out into a marsh or the
edge of a marsh and delineate the edge
of a very poorly drained soil
so it goes with the 50 foot
where does 50 foot where does 50 feet
get cut off
now the new hampshire shoreline water
quality protection act has some guidance
relative to a shoreline you go through
the sort of narrowest point on it on a
50 foot length
if i were to do that as a wetland
scientist it would triple the cost to
the town for me to delineate a wetland
so that's in other words it's not going
to happen without a bill like this now i
know that there are several people that
probably would prefer that this bill
doesn't come into place
but i would incur
representative spang's comments that
this is a
local option that's what it's called a15
is a local option it's up to the town
and it's a voluntary one as barbara
richter spoke it is one that is not easy
to get through it requires a
considerable expense and yes we do
communicate directly
through mail to every a butter to a
potential or candidate prime wetland
i also would like to point out that no
ditches are going to be approved by a
town boat it's mo it is more than
difficult to get everyone on board to
even designate a prime wetland by a
local option let alone get it approved
by the state
i as a certified wetland science will
not include ditches i will not include
narrow waterways that do not contain
significant functions for this purpose
that would be against the ethical
underpinning of my certification as a
wetland scientist i will only designate
or propose to designate those wetlands
that are the highest and the most
valuable wetlands in the state
and in that regard i'd like to point out
two small pieces of statistics to
contradict some of what you've heard as
far as testimony goes today
we have roughly in our new hampshire
wetlands
update map roughly 4.8 percent of the
state is wetland
another 3 to 3.2 percent is open water
body lakes and ponds
in other words we have a small
percentage of the landscape that is
wetland and if you calculate the amount
of prime wetlands there are in this
state at present it comes to about point
one seven percent of the entire wetland
resource
point one seven percent
okay
so
these claims that it's going to disrupt
development and disrupt
forest activity
are false
the total area of even if the hundred
foot buffer was still present the total
area of forest land around all all of
the prime wetlands is four percent of
the landscape in these towns
now
please keep in mind that
as a wetland scientist we're looking for
wildlife function functional value we
have to in order to designate a prime
last time i checked most of our species
in new hampshire prefer a forested
habitat not a clear-cut one but a
forested habitat in order for that
function to be intact
and in fact in my recent mapping of
fitzwilliam prime wetlands i found a
number of areas that i excluded from
designation because of damage done by
forestry
those areas had been compromised i did
not designate them and i will continue
to act that way and i think the state
will recognize if in the absence of that
functional value there is no basis or
validity to designate a prime wetland so
again to go to contradict some of those
statements that have been made that
would make you think perhaps that this
is going to take away everybody's right
to do what they want on their property
that is not true i would counter by
saying the flood water storage is going
to save lives
the drinking water recharge value of
these fingers and toes is going to
provide clean well water
and try and replace wells when they get
contaminated by road salt we made the
exemption for dot
we had to right i mean that was
necessary
we made exemptions for the agc even
though they now oppose it we actually
reached a compromise with them
in 2019 they went along with that
compromise we had the bill passed now
they're against it and i can tell you
singularly they are because of the new
rules that have to do with the december
2019 passage of the wetland rules which
elevates prime wetlands to a priority
resource area
that's why they're opposing this it's
not because of the prime wetlands itself
it's because they're now pras
i understand those concerns i work on
both sides of the fed i work for
development and i work for conservation
but i would underscore the fact that
this
bill is really the only key to allowing
towns to
voluntarily designate their highest and
best wetlands for the functional values
that continue to serve the populace of
the state of new hampshire and with that
i will conclude my remarks i thank you
for your time and be happy to answer any
questions you have
thank you thank you very much
paul any questions for the witness
sir i see no questions there being none
uh
chair uh recognizes
pollock
the new hampshire home home builders
mr
is here
yeah
he's here
okay mr pollock
mr pollock
good morning
that is that is complicated howard
throws you out but then brings you back
but i think i'm here now can you hear me
all right
the four floor is yours thank you very
much mr chairman and members of the
committee i'm ari pollock of gallagher
callahan and gartrell
i'm here this morning on behalf of the
homebuilders association of new
hampshire the association opposes hb 158
largely for the reasons mentioned by
gary abbott of the agc
we also oppose the bill for the same
reasons we opposed house bill 326 which
you heard earlier had been vetoed and
house bill 1124 which you heard earlier
had been tabled
we appreciate that the bill includes
prior compromises that were discussed
along the legislative trail
but we opposed the bill then and we
still do now
in short the bill puts otherwise
developable land farther off the table
for development
development in wetlands in new hampshire
already requires a permit regulated by
the state new
department of environmental services and
this process already provides for a
discussion with regulators about how
proposed impacts can be
minimized and avoided and where not
minimized or avoided mitigated and
frankly whether the mitigation proposal
is ultimately sufficient municipalities
and usually speaking through their
conservation commission
are notified of wetlands applications
and they already have a voice in this
process and des is already able to
consider that voice and those opinions
developers understand frankly and home
builders in particular that mitigation
doesn't always work
and that sometimes even the most
thoughtful and professional of
applications are denied
development in new hampshire is a hard
enough process already and this bill
puts another thumb on the scale against
the opportunity for
responsible development the bill would
apply to private land and for
designated areas
would add hurdles to permitting
supporters have mentioned on a couple of
occasions that the wetland designation
as prime is voluntary i would suggest
for you that it isn't voluntary for the
landowner who may be in the unfortunate
position of defending land rights
against his or her municipal officers
for the purpose of protecting those land
rights and i'm sure you can all imagine
that that's a tough a tough and uphill
battle
interestingly the bill exempts dot from
these challenges and the extra hurdles
that
prime wetland designations
would present and to me this means that
development on public land is somehow
more important than development on
private land and frankly i don't see the
difference rules are rules
if there are only 30 plus municipalities
uh taking advantage of this opportunity
and that amounts to
less than a quarter of a percent of land
i'm not sure throwing another curveball
at development
is necessary when a housing and
workforce crisis already exists in new
hampshire and there are already many
initiatives underway to try and bridge
that gap and that crisis
lastly we think there's quite a bit of
room for expert disagreement over
wetlands characteristics
and whether a wetland is quote
significant contributing or contributory
these disagreements can be lengthy
costly unpredictable and private land
rights are hanging in the balance
throughout this discussion for all these
reasons the home builders ask as they
have in the past that
hb 158 be found in expedient to
legislate thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for taking my
testimony
thank you
no no questions from the committee i see
no questions for me no questions thank
you very much my pleasure thank you
chair recognizes
uh
michael parsons
the new hampshire association of natural
resource
scientists
mr parsons
yes sir he's good
are you ready
are you there
mr parsons
is there a second ago so much
mr
you there
you are you are i'm new
unmute please
okay now can you hear me
yeah uh we can't see you but we can hear
you okay
uh hang on i can start my video
okay you're ready
okay very good hello uh my name is
michael
i'm an independent consultant certified
wetland scientist
and i'm the vice president of the new
hampshire association of natural
resource scientists
and i am representing the new hampshire
association of natural resource
scientists and testifying against house
bill 158
there are a couple of things i've heard
that i want to clarify keep this short
not repeat a lot of what you've already
heard
a prime wetland is intended to be the
best of the best wetland systems always
has been
the expansion to cover narrower areas
will include wetlands that are not at
that same level
and they were not ever actually included
in the past as was mentioned uh
previously
the the issue was the definition of
prime wetland initially it was based on
very poorly drained soils
and it was recognized that there were
plenty of areas
that were large wetland systems
that would include very poorly drained
and poorly drained soils
so that definition was changed in part
as rick van de pol spoke
because you can't get out and delineate
between a poorly and very poorly out in
a deep a deep wet area
but then there needed to be the uh
clarification of how far would those
very poorly i'm sorry would those prime
wetland areas extend and that's where
the concept of the 50-foot cut-off came
in
certainly there could be discussion
about whether that number
needs to change
maybe it gets lessened
but the idea to open this up to all
these narrow fingers and toes as they're
called
becomes a more difficult issue of
expansion we believe is an appropriate
expansion of the prime wetland
areas of being the best of the best
systems
the designated methodology being used to
assess prime wetland functions
is a an assessment methodology called
the new hampshire method
and it's not that
des has 12 criteria it's the new
hampshire method has these criteria and
the new hampshire method is designated
to be used to designate these prime
wetland areas
the uh the only thing is that the new
hampshire method wasn't designed for
this purpose
and it wasn't designed to uh be
evaluating systems that are
under two acres in size
which is the issue you'll get into if
you start to bring in these narrower
areas and attempt to be using it to
designate the function values of those
areas
so
narrow drainage areas really need to
have a different type of valuation
so in order to maintain protection of
the prime wetland areas the idea was is
that crop any crossings that need to be
utilized to access adjacent lands
for allowable usages
adjacent to these primal areas these
narrower smaller areas would be the
appropriate location to put any approved
crossings to be applied for through the
wetlands bureau
so there's still protection of all these
wetlands through the process of the
permitting but if you take away and you
add all these narrow areas into the
prime wetlands you now have an issue of
where are you going to cross
to access these lands
you no longer have a distinction in the
designation between the best of the best
and these narrow channels
pretend potentially channels
now it's also important to recognize is
that local communities can establish
their own rules and protections over
wetland systems and quite many of them
do
the wetlands bureau system of permitting
has very specific requirements of
protection and the towns can increase
the requirements at their will
if they wish to
so they can add buffers they can add
greater protections in areas and that's
our recommendation as the method to
protect these areas in question would be
to encourage local communities in more
specific circumstances to protect those
specific areas that they're looking to
have
increased protection over
that way you're not encumbering all the
prime wellness throughout the state of
new hampshire
with this expansion of the designation
now the uh
it was mentioned that minimal areas have
been affected up to this point i think
rick said 0.17 percent
uh but be clear that if you do change
the rules the way this bill does that
number will shoot through the roof and
increase significantly because of the
expansion of the prime mountain
designation
that's our belief and that's our
testimony as association natural
resource scientists
thank you and if you have any questions
i'll be glad to entertain them thank you
with any questions from members of the
committee
sure so i see no questions there being
none thank you very much
thank you
uh final person uh like maybe two people
uh christopher albert
um
neutral
mr uh
dr albert
are you there
he's up
right mr albert
i think you have to
let's release mr carson
my hair there i am
all right mr thank you
members of the committee thank you yeah
it is kind of where it takes it out and
back in again again for the record uh my
name is uh chris albert owner of csa
environmental consultants i'm a licensed
wetland scientist
uh i was part of nanners back in 2017
when we did the uh
the buffer uh
workshops uh documents that are being
referenced today
and i also teach at the t2 class the
culvert certification class for uh d.o.t
and road agents so again i'm mixed on
this legislative process
again uh i item 1d
uh as far as the uh
exemptions for work within those
roadways that that is very key for d.o.t
and the road agents uh trying to do any
type of roadway work
adjacent to these prime wetlands again a
lot of it got taken out in
with the legislative process but it's
good that we've got some stiff language
in there to reiterate that
um i did do a project for the town of
beau
on bulldog road back before 2012 and it
took
months to get my permitting through just
to work on a roadway with the jason
wetlands so again
item 1d is important legislative process
that needs to be in there
again i do
work as far as uh do concur with uh mike
croissant and uh nanners that uh 1b
uh should be stricken uh from the
amendment
again it's going to add lots of little
fingers
uh we have no idea
how many other wetlands this would
involve getting pulled into the
prime wetland aspect so again i
just wanted to state my concern on these
two aspects uh again i'm
in favor of one aspect of the bill and
against the other aspect
and again i'll take any questions thank
you for your time
thank you any questions by members of
the committee
sir i see no questions there being no
questions thank you very much for your
testimony
uh finally uh
i'm going to recognize donna gomash if
she's available she i just gotta
have an email that
was
not certain if you wish to testify
i know you're it's the name email
relevant to the to the shield
of gamache
uh are you there are you on she's up she
needs to argue you have to unmute
you need to unmute
are you
there donna gamache are you there
so she's up but she's muted you are
muted
you are muted
not a gamache you are muted
you put your camera on okay let me get
my camera on no let me see hold on one
second
trying to open up i had i was
doing can't seem to open my screen to
make it larger so that i can put my
camera on
so
you can testify uh you know we see your
name but we'd rather hear you than
i'm sorry i'm very sorry and i only
signed in in opposition and sent a
letter to the committee because my
wetlands expert could not join me today
so we are opposed for multiple reasons i
can i could get my wetlands expert um to
share more with you but i couldn't get
him to join me which is why i did not
sign in to testify and i i'm sorry to do
that to you i hope that helps
probably if you wish just
have them put something in writing and
send it to the committee i will get more
detail from him to the committee thank
you for that thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
there are no other hands
there being no no one else wishing to
testify
i will close the hearing
close the hearing on
house bill 158
and with that
we'll go into
house bill 426
chair opens the
hearing on the house bill
chair recognizes representative
representative spang
to present the bill
thank you mr
thank you mr chair and
members of the committee wherever you
may be
um how the
this bill is the result of the work of
the shoreline septic system study
commission
of which i was the chair uh it was a
two-year commission and
very well representative of of uh
municipal people developers
uh
the uh
septic evaluators and assessors
um and of course conservationists who
are interested in protecting surface
waters
90 of the commission members voted to
accept
the commission's recommendations
it was established to address the
critical and difficult challenge
of the threat to water quality biseptic
systems particularly the older ones that
are located close to
surface waters
when we were doing our studies they
presented that a significant proportion
of the polluted pollution of lakes and
ponds and rivers can be attributed to
underperforming septic systems
in
1967 statutes were were instituted that
require that state permits be
obtained for a septic system
but before 1967
at the
septic systems were not required to have
any approval and they have had no state
oversight ever since
and for various reasons
lack of maintenance is a big problem or
changes more intensive intensive use of
resonances
even
septic systems that were given permits
since 1967 which you
could calculate as over 50 years old may
have since become inadequate
and potential polluters of groundwater
and surface water
ex
the rub is that except when a property
is expanded or is sold there are
currently no regulatory means for
discovering that they are a problem
septic system
far less requiring that they address
so the commission um
was looking for other options other than
regulatory so we went to
um the voluntary education
financial incentives um
and uh and working directly with
landowners to see if we couldn't get
landowners to take more responsibility
for their systems
um
they
this was
this was very successful in the areas
where intensive work was done with the
uh
with the landowners and on one new
hampshire lake
the blooms of dangerous cyanobacteria
were completely wiped out by having a
very high proportion of the landowners
looking at their septic systems having
them evaluated and having them repaired
when necessary but this is clearly not
a model for solving the problem
statewide
so um we we turn them to the option or
the opportunity for when a pri when a
septic system or a property is
exchanging hands because there is
already an assessment required for the
site to make sure that it can
accommodate
a septic system
the the rub is that
the property if there's a system itself
on the property there is right now no
way that
that system would be evaluated and
somebody who is buying that property
would have no idea that the septic
system that is on it was substandard in
terms of the building that is on us or
what they are planning to put on it
um
so it's uh it's a big problem for the
landowners
so
this bill it targeted only as as the
commission was charged with doing it
charges only the older systems those
have never had a permit
or the ones that are 20 years old which
means that they could be expected to
have
to be performing in a way that might not
meet current des standards
the assessments for both the site and
the evaluation of the septic system
itself are provided to the buyer
as well as to des and the local health
official
now
it's true that the cost of evaluating a
system
will add somewhat to the cost of the
property which as we know the cost of
properties is now very high and doesn't
seem to be deterring people
from buying them
but this expense is minor compared to
the cost for an uninformed buyer to
uh
to buy a
property that has a septic system that
he then finds has to be completely
redone
and when you look at the bigger issue
what what we're really getting at which
is
saving our surface waters from being
contaminated
saving our groundwater from being
contaminated by
underperforming septic systems
the amount that it that is spent
by the buyer
in a an individual transaction
is minuscule compared to the public
benefit and the cost of
remediating a series of underperforming
septic systems so the commission felt
that this was a reasonable way to
approach this problem
it also although it will also give us
some data on how many of the septic
systems are actually performing well
so for once the the des will have some
inventory at some
at some level
of the septic systems that are good and
the ones that are
in need of of being addressed
it does not require that the buyer do
anything with this septic system it
merely
um informs them
now that
the
the first section that talks about
develop waterfront property
is
is to bring that the uh that 250 feet
buffer into alignment with the buffer
for the shoreland uh water quality
protection act and that needed to be
done because there was some confusion
about that
um i would be happy to answer any
questions
are there any questions for
representative spain representative
gunski we have a question thank you mr
chair
good morning representative good morning
i was curious
this does seem to have some kind of
financial impact but there's no fiscal
note with the bill
was that considered and if so what's
your thoughts on that
well of course uh the financial impact
if we were going to get a uh
an in
a fiscal note that only implies or it
only measures the fiscal impact for the
state of new hampshire
and you can ask the same question of des
whether this will
increase cost to them
as i've said it will increase the cost
this cost of having the evaluation will
be tacked on to
the cost of the transaction
now whether the buyer pays that or the
seller pays that or they divide it it is
up to them
okay
good thank you
representative for question
yes thank you for taking my question
it has to do with um section one the
definition of develop waterfront
i wondered one why did they add 50 more
feet from 200 to 250
but my second part is
i tried to read the statute and the
reference line when i went to rsa
483 b4
sub roman numerals
it gave me when i looked at the chart
elevations of the water of the pond
i can't figure out how do you calculate
whether it's the 200 or 250 from an
elevation in the pond are you able to
answer that question representative yeah
yeah i've been wrestling with this too
because we have um when we wrote the
shoreland protection act and when we're
looking at um the definition of a stream
with rivers and things
it's uh
it's called the reference line and it is
defined differently for salt water and
fresh water and for fresh water that is
impounded by a dam
so with salt water it's the highest
observable tide
for fresh water it's pretty much the
same
and for uh fresh water that's damned of
course it's the height of the dam so
that determines where that reference
line is which determines which is
basically saying this is the high water
level this is where the you know the
i don't have to explain this to you
um but
so then it's measured back from there
what happens within that 250 feet
is defined in further regulations like
in the shoreline protection act they
have
one one thing that can and cannot happen
within that that 250 feet
the
um
there were studies that were done
particularly
an exhaustive study that was done around
great bay because as you know there are
very serious uh pollution problems there
that showed that 250 feet setback is
required
to protect the the bay and its
tributaries from contamination by septic
systems
so this seemed to be a good place to
start
it doesn't necessarily and
it doesn't necessarily
imply that particular regulations are
applying to those it just sets the zone
and then what happens within that zone
is determined in other statutes like the
shoreland
okay
that answer your question representative
yes i think the representative by
telling me that it's from the high
watermark or the shoreline i tried to
calculate how how do i cover the 250
and i appreciate that you're tying this
into the shoreline protection act
distance thank you thanks
any additional questions
i see no additional questions
uh the chair has a question uh
the bill as i as i read it says that
the
the septa systems
uh really basically says
concern that they're not built
to today's
standards and uh
it doesn't say that they don't work
well this is why um
this is where it gets interesting if
you've been studying it for two years
um
you'll notice that it doesn't assume
that they don't work
it's just saying we had to
decide
which
systems were
unlike we're likely to be um beginning
to to fail and therefore should be
subject to having
having an evaluation
and the uh you'll if the evaluation
looks good then that's the end of the
story
but it just says that
this is saying
we're going to look at these systems
because they are the ones that are most
likely to have a problem the
understanding is that many of them won't
um but right now we've got systems on
houses that have been built for 75 years
that are still operating on a
55 gallon drum
and we have no way of
of addressing that of getting them
[Music]
getting them examined
the we also have instances where a house
that
uh now has a washing machine and uh etc
etc and people are living there full
time that weren't before and their
system was built
uh to accommodate
one bedroom
so that
it is not a way of saying that we're
presuming that they're bad it's a way of
saying
these are the ones that we should if
we're going to limit them but ones that
we ex that we look at then these are the
ones that are most likely to have a
problem does that help
uh i'll go on to a different question
uh
who is
who is there is there appears to be a
a policing function here is there not
and who who does that policing function
what if someone doesn't
doesn't bother to do this
what is the
what is the penalty and who does it
well there's this it falls underneath
the um the existing statute which is
waterfront property sale the rsa 485 a
39 which already requires that a site
assessment study be done
and with a not only the assessment of
the site but also identifying the
name and address of the seller and the
seller's agent and the
identifying the lot
um
and then so that it would come under the
same that that same statute that they
would be
enforced together now as i said if the
system is found to be substandard
no one is going to force the uh
the buyer to do anything about it
but we at least will know that that that
the system is a problem
des would probably be best at telling
you
about the enforcement and how they will
interpret the findings of these
evaluations
uh also
the additional question concerning
the the sale of property if someone uh
can the
buyer
waive the rights uh for this
uh for the
for this study basically by
agreeing to it as is purchased
and
so basically the seller
can say you're buying the product the
product the property as is
and would that negate the use of this
function
that um
that makes sense if we're just
considering the impact on the buyer but
we're also considering whether or not
the state is going to be able to
identify where
potentially polluting
septic systems are and that's where we
do need to have the report sent to des
and the
municipal health
health
officer
thank you
any other questions members of the
committee
no further questions there being none
thank you very much for your testimony
uh senator he was the next person i'm
going to call as a member as a
senator waters are you there
how's he making up
he's
coming up
okay
yeah he is uh he is there
all right do you have me now
uh we got you all right well thank you
and uh good morning mr chairman members
of the committee uh i'm senator david
waters district 4 which is barrington
over
roundsford and somersworth and i'm here
as a co-sponsor to testify in support of
house bill
426.
i want to offer to the committee the
perspective of all the communities
around the great bay and we've been
dealing uh you know really for decades
now with the
uh problem of nitrogen pollution in the
great bay
and in particular uh this has led to a
long-standing contest or battle or fight
whatever you want to call with the uh
with the epa
um over its uh permitting and licensing
requirements for
our wastewater treatment plants around
the bay
uh and as we know the feds regulate what
they can wait they can regulate and
about 40 percent of
the nitrogen source was coming from the
wastewater treatment plants and i would
say that communities around the bay have
spent north of 200 million dollars
over the last uh 10 years upgrading
their wastewater
treatment plants and you know really
stepped up we want to clean bay it's
important for the economy in the area
uh and for real estate sales um
but then the epa was going to come in
and put a standard which most folks
thought was going to be impossible
to meet
for
you know to further reduce the nitrogen
pollution so the negotiation which took
several years was reached a few years
you know a few months ago
and the ep says a said okay look
you can develop efforts to reduce
nitrogen pollution from all kinds of
sources
and if you can do that and it's going to
be a savings of you know another 100
million dollars to the communities the
taxpayers
then you're going to be okay
now following on top of that is the new
regulations you know over the last
several years over ms4 the municipal
storm
sewer system
basically storm water runoff which is
another source of nitrogen deposition
into the
into the bay and you know estimates
raised from you know from 400 million to
a billion dollars um unless we can find
different ways to
to deal with uh with with that that
issue
um then the other component of course uh
are is the other you know non-point
sources uh or things like septic systems
and um
so that that's what comes into play with
this
this bill
uh the impacts of the nitrogen in
general on the bay uh you know it the
eelgrass dies and that's kind of a
barometer of the health of the water
there
but this impacts all kinds of
resources in the bay
we have a booming aquaculture
business about 44 growers of oysters
right now
if you like to go fish on the coast of
new hampshire or elsewhere
great bay is one of the largest spawning
grounds for fish
on the whole east coast um
and so the economy you know the
recreational fishing economy the uh
aquaculture economy these these are big
deals
but you know one incident of uh bad
runoff out of the wastewater plants or
uh a faulty
septic system and you're gonna put
somebody out out of business if their
aquaculture operation is near
there
so what the communities
are now able to do under this new
agreement with the epa is to look at all
these sources and to develop the lowest
cost ways
of addressing them and uh you know as a
taxpayer in dover where we've seen our
water rates go up and up and up like
everybody else around the bay um this is
music to our ears if there are things
that municipalities can do to reduce
these sources then we're going to save a
lot of a lot of money
um so that's why this bill is so
important uh it it lets us uh in the
municipalities um go out work with
property owners see where there might be
problems if there aren't they're good
where they're good to go
if there are problems
you know i think homeowners are going to
want to step up uh you know we
in this in new hampshire we respect our
neighbors and we all want to keep our
property taxes low so i think this is a
real good practical step give something
into the toolbox and municipalities to
to help us out and uh for those of you
who aren't around the great bay um you
know this is a real this is a real big
issue and it's also potentially going to
affect a lot of the ms4 communities you
know up and down the merrimack river and
other parts on the seacoast that fall
into this ms4
regulation and uh municipalities they've
got to deal with it and this is another
way they could negotiate with the feds
that let's look at the overall nitrogen
where it comes from and
not got hammered on the most expensive
response that that might might be asked
for
so thank you mr chairman and i'll be
glad to take any questions
any questions for the senator
from the members of the committee
mr uh representative post uh
representative post for a question
yes uh thank you mr chairman for taking
my question and um thank you for coming
today senator waters my question is has
there been um
is there a regulation or has there been
any work done
with
nitrogen coming from
fertilizing your lawns i know
when we go on the lakes we see
beautiful waterfront properties with
great big expansive lawns that are green
even in drought conditions so
[Music]
if you could answer that for me
well thank you for your question and uh
you know fertilizer
runoff is an is an issue around the
great bay as well and uh you know i've
got a lot of ponds and lakes in my
district too so i really know about this
and
there have been various attempts really
two-fold to look at regulation
representative um cahill has sponsored
some
uh regulation on this and then prior to
them i came from the name of the
representative who represented newmarket
before him um also
looking at this issue
um
and uh it's difficult you know i think
that there are
you know that how far back do you say
somebody can't use a certain product
but the good news here is that there has
been a lot of work also with the
fertilizer manufacturers um scott for
example and others have agreed to change
their formulation
and if you have solar release and if you
change the formulation of you know what
kind of phosphates and so on are in it
you can reduce uh this problem so it's a
big issue um you know i'm i'm always you
know a little
careful about telling anybody what to do
they can do or they can't do in their
property right you know i i think that's
awfully important
um but i think this is an area that we
can work on but it's one of those places
where if we can work with the industry
and work with the
with the municipalities i think that's a
way to go on that one thank you for your
question
um mr chairman may have a follow-up for
a follow-up
so so i guess my concern in this all um
while i agree with you about homeowner
rates of being able to use their
property um i i wonder how much we
this is only forty percent where's the
sixty percent coming from
um
and and is there a greater um
[Music]
place to look than doing this that would
have um
a bigger impact
well thanks for your question and um i
don't have the statistics right in in my
mind i know the municipal wastewater
treatment is 40
and then the breakout after that is um
certainly the stormwater is a very big
component especially in the cities where
you've got a lot of paved
surface doesn't make so much difference
in a lot of the
of the towns but then after that the
natural there's natural deposition just
from the atmosphere um you know we cut
down some of that when the
ohio power plants stopped belching it
over to us but it's also tailpipe
emission that just comes down with the
with the rain and um then there the the
advantage of looking at septic is that
it is a really addressable point of
source
um so that and and it can really
have a large impact on a very small area
we're talking about wiping out an oyster
farm for
for example or
a particular kind of neighborhood that
is has is a
budding ashore which has
marsh grass and eelgrass there um and
that so i'm not exactly answering your
question but i think that why the
municipalities have wanted to take the
you know all of the above approach
is that in their own municipality they
might identify we don't have much of a
problem with septic we don't have much
septic
um other municipalities will say well
we've got no we really have no storm
water system but we the septic one is is
that so it's flexibility is what this
bill is about
thank you very much for your
clarification on that i appreciate it
all right thank you
questions see uh seeing no more
questions thank you very much senator
thank you mr chairman have a good day
the chair recognizes christopher albert
uh you have
10 minutes time can you cut that
significantly please
mr albert are you there
you
showed up
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee again chris albert back again
i'm a licensed septic designer licensed
septic evaluator
i'm actually chairman of the new
hampshire oplc evaluator board
and was one of the members uh with uh
judas
representative spang on the shoreline
committee uh today i represent jisawa
which used to be grant state designers
and scholars
again we're the non-profit group of the
uh
septic designers evaluators pumpers in
the state uh our board of directors uh
we've reviewed uh house bill 426
and have some concerns comments uh about
the uh the bill again it's a good start
place uh you know during the study
committee we looked at you know where do
we tackle first so i think looking at
the uh
you know the shoreline uh site
assessments is a key one it's kind of a
weak uh law that's in place
the issue we have though is
in in in the bill language
they talk about
having licensed septic evaluators
do this study report
unfortunately through the licensing
process a licensed septic evaluator
is not qualified
uh with the env thousand subsurface
rules
uh
understanding water tables and test bits
and and knowing uh the components of a
leech field to that level so that's
something where uh again we would
probably want to have that aspect of it
stricken from the bill
and strictly be licensed septic
designers i know there was discussion
about the the fiscal impact
uh
you know there is should it should be
noted uh and i'm sure the realtors will
chime in later on of what this cost
uh will present for site assessments
right now
a given case i i may charge only 400 to
do a site assessment it's it's a quick
process
uh it is by statutory law that uh my my
forms that i fill out both the owner
the buyer and the seller both have to be
signed that form but again that form
doesn't go anywhere it doesn't go to des
it doesn't go to the health officer so
this is this is a good start of a bill
that can track it at the state level but
then there is that fiscal impact and i
think uh
the department will be weighing in
shortly uh about you know how this will
cost them you know what do they do with
this information you know how do they
qualize it
and file it
from that standpoint
and there's no real end result with this
bill
you know a lot of times on these
transfer properties if there is a failed
leech field or for substandard
will come in as part of an escrow or
closing
to put in a feed or have that system
replaced
so there's no extra you know where it's
going to go
uh again so the key really uh
for us is that we'd like to have this
bill go to study uh and working with
representative spang and the bill's
sponsors and the department to really
excuse me clean up the
site assessment process and give it some
more teeth
uh
again but where it goes from there it
needs again it needs more study
thank you chairman and the committee and
i'll be happy to take any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions from the
uh chair recognizes representative
gunski thank you mr chairman
i thank you sir for taking my question
looking at the current statute
in this site assessment does do you or
your farm do you perform this this uh
section abc assessment currently yes i
do i do i do quite a few site
assessments uh for closings within that
that 200 foot that buffer so again
having her language change from two to
250 is is appropriate to fall in line
with the shoreline but again it's
you know my fees are pretty minor uh
it's it's really i and unfortunately i
hate to say it the department may
be agree disagree but i i feel the
current laws that are out there is kind
of a lemon law it's kind of walking
around the car that you're about to
buy and you kick the tires
and you know the car the tires don't
sink so the car is okay it's really not
doing good justice
to the buyers and sellers on this
transfer of these waterfront properties
so this is a good spot uh to start in in
trying to clean up
uh non-point source nitrogen sources in
state of new hampshire uh again it just
it needs some good reworking that's all
mr general for a follow-up thank you sir
this new section section b that we're
really
discussing would your firm you had
mentioned a new hampshire permitted
septic system designer
uh
so are we now asking to have a another
individual or another another firm
involved other than a firm like yourself
no they're already the way the bill is
written it's it's it allows either a
designer or an evaluator
to perform this evaluation you know
through this new bill what we're saying
is that the evaluator should be stricken
from the bill language that the
evaluator through
the state's licensing process isn't the
proper person
to do this type of evaluation it should
be the licensed septic designer uh as as
part of the written uh text
one more i just think it's a good
question
for a follow-up
are
are you sure you're firm
are you a septic system evaluator i'm
both a wetland scientist septic system
designer and evaluator okay thank you
very much
any other questions from the members of
the committee seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank you
recognizes
uh
lee oxendam
representative
in support
is she there
yes sir
representative oxnam yes thank you i had
difficulty getting on thank you very
much i'll i'll be very brief i want to
congratulate the commission
that worked on
did we lose you
uh what brad is suddenly on the brad
brainland just
she should be that concerned okay
remember brad hello am i back
uh you're back now thank you uh
again i'll be very brief especially
because it seems like my internet is um
not behaving well it's going in and out
yes so i'm supporting the bill it's
essential that we protect water quality
our surface waters our streams our
rivers our lakes
our tourism recreation businesses depend
on new hampshire being a beautiful
welcoming safe place for people to come
with their families
this is a a small fee that would be uh
attached and it would give the state the
ability to track problems should they
arise it can save des money over time if
they say there you know we have five
cottages on this lake that have been
identified as having septic systems that
are over 20 years let's go and look
there first to see if they are the
source of the problem i i think it's a
very good start and i'll i'll stop right
there thank you
thank you very much if you've got any
no questions from the uh from the
members of the committee
uh chair will recognize
lee merrill
from the new hampshire association of
realtors in opposition to the bill
how long have you uh
wished to speak
there's
lynn merrill so she's absolutely man
she's she's up
she's coming up yep
she needs to i'm you
uh
lynne merrell
here
okay good how long do you wish to speak
um three minutes
and if um
the chair would allow
i have a colleague with me uh this
morning and rather than having to speak
separately i'd like to have ken muller
also speak with me
okay i'll allow that to
you flip do you have your uh
visual your
camera on
there huh
oh okay
here we go
sorry about that
that's fine continue
okay
mr chair members of the committee
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to speak to house bill 426
we are pleased to have represented the
new hampshire association of realtors on
the study commission that brought forth
this bill
while serving on the commission we
thought we were making progress
to bring an understanding of how septic
system inspections and waterfront
property site assessments work to
protect both water quality and buyers
unfortunately this bill does not reflect
that progress
the current process is not broken
most if not all buyers
have a septic inspection done as part of
their purchase
if problems are found
they have opportunities to renegotiate
the price
withdraw from the purchase
or insist that the seller fix
the system before purchasing
no realtor seller or buyer wants to have
a property that causes new hampshire's
lakes ponds or rivers to be polluted by
a septic system
problem properties are being discovered
during the real estate sell and buy
process
and they're being fixed to today's
standards without being mandated
um is ken on
were you able to let ken into the zoom
[Music]
is he there mr muller
i'm here thank you very much mr chair
all right
continue uh
okay we have four major points of
concern
um one is moving from 250 to 200 feet
will affect hundreds if not thousands of
properties that would not come under the
current rsa
the measurement from the reference line
is not to the septic system or to the
building under the current rsa but any
portion of the parcel so that means if
one little corner of your property line
lies within the
um you would be subject to this
new addendum part of the rsa
and number two if the subject inspection
report is sent to health official in a
municipality
and it shows that it's non-conforming to
current des standards then what
and if it's functioning are they going
to do something are they going to make
it conform and conforming can be like a
few years ago they changed the tank size
from a thousand to two 1250 gallons that
doesn't mean the system is failed it
just means the tank size according to ds
should have been increased
yet we have plenty of thousand gallon
septic systems that are
well on their way uh working very well
so will they insist on the silver make
conforming if not in failure or a
compromise in any way so we have big
concerns about the sort of vagueness of
that particular portion of the
amendment
we also
right now under
the current
site assessment rsa
des does not receive anything so if they
do receive it
what are they going to do with them are
they going to create a database and is
that going to
incur staff time and i'm sure bes will
address those issues with you but we
have concerned about what that actually
means and will there be costs incurred
relative to that and a site assessment
is prepared by a waste disposal designer
a septic inspection is prepared by a
licensed septic evaluator these are two
separate professions that need to
coordinate to work on one assessment
because currently the rsa calls for a
septic designer to do a site assessment
this calls for
a septic evaluator so during the process
of a purchase and sale typically a buyer
gets to choose who they want and we
think it's a consumer issue in that
right now under this proviso
the seller would be obligated to
actually do the septic inspection
and they would deny the buyer a choice
as to whether they want to use their own
which is the current process and that's
what it goes through
these two separate professions and this
legislation requires that both create
the report currently a site assessment
is prepared by the designer we think
that's a conflict um you've already been
addressed it
but we we don't know how to evaluate
that where two different people would
have to do the evaluation on this so
those are our concerns and lynn has a
following conclusion okay
the marketplace right now is
allows buyers to have a septic
inspection as a condition of the
purchase and sale agreement it's
actually in the purchase and sale
agreement giving them the opportunity to
have that septic inspection the seller
already has a disclosure mandated by law
that is also
given to the buyer prior to purchasing
the property
so the buyer is fully aware of the size
of the septic system what it looks like
when they purchase the property
should an issue arise during the
inspection of course they can negotiate
how they want to handle it
under
um and i think the rest of that is more
or less repetitious but the most
important thing that i'd like to say is
that
realtors buyers and sellers all want to
protect the water and we do believe that
the current system is working perfectly
fine
um the majority of buyers the vast
majority of buyers have a septic
inspection prior to purchase
the few that don't we are seeing a few
others in this economy that are not
because of the competitiveness of
um
of the market
but those that don't are generally
people that understand that if there's
an issue they'll have to do something
about it and are usually
in a financial position to take care of
that
so we have we do believe the current
system is working and we think that this
bill needs a good deal of work before it
can move forward
thank you very much
mr chair one other thing i'd like to
mention to piggyback on what lynn just
said um july will start my 50th year in
real estate and i have never sold a
property that hasn't had a septic
evaluation
but we really want to
demonstrate to the committee that we
really think it's a consumer protection
situation where the buyer should have
the choice and the buyer should get to
select who they want to evaluate their
septic
and i can assure the committee that um
even though
representative spang had mentioned that
buyers buy property and they don't know
what they're buying
it's never happened in my career and i
know in lynn's
we're very aware whether we list
property or we represent buyers we want
to make sure that they know what they're
getting and that's where the negotiation
comes and that's why
um
things get fixed and that's why
after a property gets sold there usually
is a combination for the septic system
and sometimes a septic system can work
perfectly fine
but somebody who evaluated it for them
says if you want to extend the life of
elite field you need to put a venting
system in or you might want to replace
that d box and even little things that
don't affect uh
whether it's failed or passed those
things do get addressed and a lot of
times the sellers will do that or the
buyer will take it upon themselves to
fix it after the fact so thank you very
much mr chairman we're happy to take any
questions
before i help with the questions uh
ms merrill or mr mueller have you uh
submitted this your testimony uh to this
committee
we will right after this hearing
i would appreciate that thank you
kelly for a question
representative kelly for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you both
for being here today um my question uh
mr albert had mentioned before that uh
septic evaluators aren't
um qualified to do the full
bleach field
uh evaluation that's necessary did i
under current law or
is the market in the current marketplace
do
do you approach a septic evaluator or a
septic designer
to have that evaluation done
we do both
the septic designer does the site
assessment
and the septic evaluator does the
inspection for the buyer
thank you
representative gunski for a question
thank you mr chair
i i believe is it
mr mueller
yes you had stated that in your 50 years
you haven't actually had a property sold
that was not uh
done with a without a septic inspection
but your counterpart had mentioned most
so
just give me your best judgment as far
as you being a professional in your
industry
is it uncommon or what kind of
percentage are we talking quantify that
like maybe statewide is it 98 99 i'm
just looking for a figure if i could
to be honest it depends on market
conditions um if the buyer thinks that
they have leverage um they're going to
put a lot of conditions on the purchase
and sale to make sure they know exactly
what they're getting
we're right now in a marketplace that in
my 50 years i've never seen where
there's
virtually no inventory whatsoever so
when a property does come up whether
it's on a lake or not on a lake um
people are tripping over themselves to
get it so a lot of times they're being
advised by people
don't put any conditions in order to get
this property but i can assure you that
i haven't sold one of those but if they
if they had been a lot of buyers even
though they're trying to secure the
property that way they will get the
inspections done either simultaneous to
waiting for the closing or immediately
after the close
so
somebody who's buying a 2 million lake
property certainly doesn't want to have
a polluting septic system on it
but they have the wherewithal to make
that happen after the fact
and i can tell you that until this year
i
never had a property without a septic
inspection
this year there have been several
without
um so i want to say maybe 95 98
have septic inspections those that don't
generally either have a brand new septic
system already in place or something
recently replaced
or
um have a or have the financial means i
did have one purchase person that did
purchase a home without a septic
inspection this year he said you know
it's going to cost me 15 to 20 000 to
put in a new system i don't want it to
affect the sale i want to buy it if i
need a new system i have the money i'll
put it in i don't i'll do that
i'll do the inspection after
the uh closing i had one other that um
did not want to do the inspection uh for
the seller to do anything but they did
indeed do the inspection uh prior to but
it was not a condition of sale it was
just so that they would know what it was
they were buying and if there was an
issue with the septic then they would uh
take care of it as soon as they moved in
thank you
representative cohen for a question
yes i have a question for mr mueller
please uh thank you for taking my
question mr muller under the current law
can a person who is selling a camp on a
lake that has a failing septic system
complete that sale and then the person
buy that camp just go about their merry
way using the camp for another 5 10
whatever years with the failing septic
system legally
um in my opinion here's what i would do
if i encountered a listing and i could
see the effluent for instance coming out
of the ground even before the site
assessment was done
what i would do is advise them that we
can't sell the property like that
but it's what we call in the business a
material defect
so every consumer that's going to look
at that property would be told by the
listing agent
uh certainly by their buying
agent that's representing them as well
that that is
has no standing plus the health officers
in town would be alerted as to a failed
septic system so to answer your question
no it wouldn't be conveyed and it
wouldn't be conveyed uh for very long
without getting fixed if it was conveyed
and i certainly if i encountered one i
would certainly report it that it's a
failed system and educate my seller as
to what needs to happen
follow-on question mr chairperson or a
follow-up yes mr mueller just for my
education how would that help officer
know that that uh system is failing you
just talked about
well in a case where it wasn't obvious
and it had us a septic evaluation done
um the site assessment actually is sort
of an observation of what they see on
the ground so it might be
caught in the site assessment
but if not when a buyer goes to buy it
and they do a septic inspection um and
they find it to be failed then they're
going to either walk away from the sale
they're going to negotiate a difference
in the price
and escrow the money um to have it fixed
prior to closing um or they're going to
um
fix it themselves uh with the monies
that they have when they purchase the
property at a reduced price
thank you for the response
okay
your your question is
the question is answered i'm fine thank
you mr chairperson thank you very much
anyone else no further questions no
further questions thank you for your
testimony thank you
all right i'm going to move right along
uh
representative
[Music]
she's not there
i do not see him okay i'll go i'll go
right along then
uh it's
uh michelle davis
uh from new hampshire lakes
for three minutes
i'm gonna hold you to your time
we're gonna start holding on to the
others
for your
are you there
hi i'm here can you hear me
uh yep
uh the floor is yours thank you uh
chairman zulo members of the committee
uh thank you for the opportunity to
comment
uh
when improperly designed installed or
maintained septic systems can pollute
our lakes ponds and rivers with an
adequately treated wastewater this
direct threat to water quality also
endangers human health and public safety
new hampshire lakes is a statewide
non-profit dedicated to keeping new
hampshire's lakes clean and healthy
and we work with partners to promote
clean water policies and responsible use
we understand that inadequate septic
systems can leach pollutants such as
phosphorus and nitrogen along with
disease-causing pathogens into nearby
surface water bodies
and in a natural increase in phosphorus
levels can cause toxic cyanobacteria
blooms which are unhealthy for wildlife
and people
and e coli found in inadequately treated
wastewater can cause serious human
illness
in in the septic study commission
process we've heard from our membership
and partners that member many new
hampshire lakeside property owners
struggle with adequately maintaining
their antiquated septic systems many of
which predate state required inspections
many of these seasonal camps have been
renovated to accommodate
three to four season living and
additional bedrooms and older on-site
septic systems are often not well
documented by the homeowner or upgraded
based on changes to property use which
results in a lack of knowledge about the
age condition and capacity of the system
and the likelihood of it being unable to
meet the demands placed upon it
a more robust septic system evaluations
at the time of property transfer is a
good way to catch underperforming
systems that are either on inspection
uninspected or the inspection of which
is out of date it's typically very easy
to identify septic systems in outright
failure but often difficult to identify
systems that are underperforming without
a more thorough inspection
the requirement to submit site
assessments to local health officials
and the new hampshire department of
environmental services will assist the
state in determining the number of
uninspected and outdated systems and
will give homeowners opportunities to
identify and update systems um so we
urge you to vote ought to pass on hp 426
which is we feel an important step
forward in addressing inadequate systems
and their threats to public health and
water quality and helping to keep new
hampshire lakes clean and healthy
thank you for your testimony any
questions about members of the committee
sure i see your questions seeing none
thank you very much thank you
diane hanley
a member of the public from representing
the lake winnipesaukee association
looks to speak for five minutes can you
shorten that up if you will
i can do that yes
let's see
so thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
lwa is a 501c3 non-profit dedicated to
protecting lake winnipesaukee's water
quality and natural resources
our work
serves and benefits the 14
municipalities located in belmap and
carroll counties and their fifty
thousand residents as well as the
hundreds of thousands of visitors that
come here each year
um we appreciate the opportunity to
comment on this particular bill
and we are urging you to support the
bill
um
the lake winnipesaukee association has
some um
actual numbers that we'd like to share
with you
um about
what we've seen on one lake which is
within our watershed lake wacky one
we
in 2016 we completed uh an evaluation of
the number of septic systems around
lake wacky one within 250 feet of the
shoreline
lake wachuan is the water supply for the
town of meredith
so we were working with the town of
meredith to to do this project
we found 181 septic systems within 250
feet of the shoreline on waukeuan
of those systems were installed before
which is the end of the average expected
20 to 30-year lifespan
and 49 of them were installed prior to
1967 which is well beyond the expected
life span of most septic systems
um we
had funding to work with homeowners
that were willing to do so
um and we
we studied and had helped them
financially
get
professional evaluations of their septic
system so there are 24 homeowners
and we were able to test 24 of those
septic systems
and we determined that 13 of them were
in failure
um so that's 54
of the systems that we were actually
testing
so that's 24 out of 181 septic systems
lake wacky one does have an issue of
nutrient loading
excess nutrients uh primarily phosphorus
and
about nine percent of that
nutrient load
is because of septic systems that's a
a report that we had done prior to 2016.
um
i would point out that prior to the
evaluation the homeowners were not aware
that their systems were in failure or
even impaired
so there were no observable
issues at the surface for several of
them
and so from our findings it is clear
that implementing uh evaluations of
older septic systems at least at the
point of sale
would clearly serve public health
there if there are no obvious
if there's no obvious data or not data
but evidence at the surface
and someone decides not to do
a
an evaluation it most certainly could
occur
that a home with a failing septic system
could be sold to someone and used by the
new owner for 10 years without them
doing anything about the septic system
so
in closing we urge you to
vote ought to pass on hp 426
and
please feel free to contact me or
patricia tarpy the executive director
with any questions
thank you
thank you very much any questions
representative gunski thank you mr
chairman
thank you for taking my question just
got a question i i
your your study on lake waukewan
was about existing homes and this
what we're hearing this bill is about
the sale
basically of a home
and is there any information as far as i
mean have any of these homes on that
particular water or body of water
especially the 24 that you did
evaluations on if they've been sold
i mean
difficult one for you to answer but do
you know if any of these have changed
ownership and how was that handled if
they were
oh um i believe that uh we don't know if
all of them we don't know the status of
all of them but i do know that at least
one of them was in the process of being
sold
um or
the intent was to sell the home right at
the time that we were doing the study
in the program
and do you have any feedback as far as
the process and how that was handled if
it was sold specifically you know if you
were if they were involved in your study
i would be really curious to find out
was there anything done in that
particular home when it was transferring
here
oh um
i believe that that property owner did
undertake a repair of the septic system
prior to the sale of the home
once they knew they were pretty
surprised
and took steps to address it
and that was that was our experience
with
several people they were pleased with uh
getting financial help to do that and
also got financial help to go ahead and
change their um
to address some of their issues with
their septic system but in general i
can't really answer your question about
what happened after the or during a sale
of any of the properties the data
one quick question i'm sorry yeah for a
follow-up
the date of that evaluation also i'm
sorry i didn't get that when you gave
the testimony what was the time frame
for that evaluation you did on rocky one
uh that was in the 2 2014 2016 time
frame
thank you very much
you're welcome thanks for your testimony
thank you
is there no further questions thank you
uh chair will recognize uh peter russell
member of the public representing gsowa
which i
need you to tell us who that is and
is he up is he up so i've got pete uh
russell
peter russell yes it might be
yahoo.com
member of the public
mr russell
yes can you hear me oh yes
you
want to turn on his
turn on his uh camera yeah
uh you're saying ten minutes uh
that's not gonna
yeah okay i'll try to be brief thank you
mr chairman and committee members my
name is peter russell i'm the owner of
russell inspection services and i also
sit on the board of directors
for granite state on-site waste water
association
and i also participated in the shoreline
septic study commission
um
i wanted to
point out today that
in the bill as it's written
again
following up on chris albert's comment
that we as licensed septic evaluators
are not qualified to determine whether a
system
is in compliance uh
with any standard
that's outside of our
license purview
we can tell you the condition of the
system
uh but
as far as whether or not it complies to
any of des
regulations um
we cannot do that i i would also like to
point out too that
site assessments and evaluations are uh
completely different
uh items so a
site assessment is more of a mapping of
septic components lot lines of butter as
well
that sort of thing
and no actual digging in the ground
takes place during a site assessment uh
septic evaluation
we would actually dig up the system
components
uh tank leachfield that sort of thing
and actually determine what the
condition of the system is
uh that's it in a nutshell and i'd be
happy to take questions from anybody
any questions by members of the
committee
representative
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question in the
current statute section b
it talks about soil type and you just
made a statement saying that you don't
actually do any digging how do we
determine the soil type that's defined
in section b
without actually getting into the soil
well that that would have to be answered
by a licensed designer
who does the
site assessment but i i think that
any information regarding soils would be
added
through historical data and not actual
digging of test fits so no no test fits
are
typically done during a site assessment
okay thank you sergeant smith
uh representative smith for a question
yeah uh thank you and thank you for
taking my question i just need a
confirmation because i didn't quite get
what you had said
um i believe you said evaluators don't
dig in the ground they just do a big
picture kind of overview of the whole
area
and then the designers do actually dig
stuff up is that correct
no i apologize that that's backwards so
they the licensed designers uh do not
actually do any digging in the ground
it's the evaluator
that would
look at the system components by
physically
opening up the tank and digging
inspection holes in the leach field
thank you very much
you're welcome
no no we see no further questions
move on to
melissa
melissa paley
conservation law foundation
see that she sure
uh
can you hear me uh yes we can uh yeah
you have your camera on
uh
sorry
i should have it on now
okay we have it
floor is yours okay thank you very much
um i appreciate your taking uh my
comments chairman and members of the
committee
um my name is melissa paley i'm the
great bay piscataqua water keeper with
the conservation law foundation you can
see the beautiful mouth of the oyster
river and little bay right
right behind my head
um uh conservation law foundation is a
non-profit member supported
environmental advocacy organization
dedicated to protecting our environment
and communities in new hampshire and
across new england
clf commends the sponsors of hb426 for
recognizing the serious impact of septic
systems
on water quality and ecosystem health in
new hampshire
um after a year actually
two years nearly of study by the
shoreline septic system study commission
chaired by representative spang and of
which i was a member
it's clear that antiquated and
underperforming septic systems which
treat waste from an estimated 85 percent
of the state's
households are a significant source of
nitrogen and phosphorus pollution
that negatively impact our freshwater
lakes and coastal rivers and bays here
in new hampshire
in the seacoast region where i focus my
efforts to protect and restore the
health of great bay piscataqua estuary
nitrogen pollution from subject systems
is a is a quite a serious concern as as
senator waters pointed out
according to the 2018 state of our
estuaries report which is a kind of a
doctor's report relation released every
five years uh by the pascatical region
estuars partnership
nearly a third of the nitrogen pollution
from diffuse non non-point sources
in the great asteroid comes from septic
systems
um and and and again as senator waters
noted
larger municipalities around this um
around our our watershed have uh paid a
lot of attention and a lot of money uh
nearly 200 million dollars to upgrade
um
much antiquated wastewater treatment
facilities and has substantially
ratcheted down the amount of nitrogen
pollution that they discharge
into our rivers and bays there are 18
wastewater treatment plants um around
this estuary
but we've paid very little attention to
the septic systems that treat waste from
tens of thousands of people about half
the population in the watershed here
even though we know that they
collectively contribute a very large
share of the nitrogen load to this
estuary
so it's really really
high time that we turn our attention to
how septic systems can be better
designed cited and regulated to protect
water quality in the health of our
rivers and bays
there were a lot of key findings in the
report issued by the septic system study
commission and i urge you to read it if
you haven't
it was released at the end of october in
and uh one of the key findings is that
you know septic systems were are a very
effective waste on-site wastewater
treatment system to take care of
bacterial pollution that could otherwise
get into our drinking water wells and
and other receiving bodies septic
systems are a technology that were not
designed to never have been designed to
mitigate nitrogen and phosphorus
pollution the so-called you know
nutrients that are
present in high quantities in human
waste
these phosphorus and nitrogen basically
flows out of a sept out of your you know
your home through the leech field
very little degradation
um and into you know groundwater
wetlands and so on
so
the systems so septic systems by
definition add nitrogen and fertile
nitrogen and phosphorus into our
groundwater and water bodies whether
they're functioning well or not and
that's really the key the key is
providing enough distance for that water
to travel so that microbes and soil and
plants can utilize those nutrients and
take them up before they get in to our
rivers and streams so it's not just
about you know the failing systems are
pretty easy to observe and the state has
a a law that you know takes care of
failing septic systems it's the ones
that are either underperforming are
poorly cited
um that are really of key concern
so the issue of how far these septic
systems are located from water bodies is
a very key consideration and an
important element of hb 426
another key finding of this of the
septic system study commission is how
widespread the lack of awareness is by
homeowners about the condition
maintenance needs and even the location
of these septic systems this out of
sight out of mind
problem compounds the challenge of
reducing water quality impacts from
septic systems
and we found that there are significant
gaps in how the systems are regulated in
new hampshire
as i said the ones that don't contain or
treat sewage those are fairly easy to
notice and des requires that these
systems be replaced but there is no
mechanism for capturing the systems that
are underperforming that are not cited
properly or that are intermittently
problematic due to changing groundwater
levels periods of more intense use of
the septic systems and other variables
and another point to consider with these
variables is that we're seeing more
variability as we experience changing
climate we have rising groundwater
levels
especially in coastal areas where we
have storm
sea level rise and increased storm surge
from the more intense
storms that we're seeing
in recent years
so one of the many recommendations of
the shoreline septic systems study
commission which as as representative
spain noted was approved by 10 of the 11
voting members is to increase the
efficacy and enforcement of rsa 485 a
especially in areas with recognized
state
designated water quality impairments
in these zones the study commission
represent recommends that
both a site assessment and a septic
system evaluation be required before a
property is sold and transferred
and this would enable des municipalities
and buyers to gain important information
about location and functionality of
these systems
and i know the realtors maintain that
you know all this happens anyway because
uh you know in the process of property
inspection but we we learned in the
commission that that is not the case and
that you know we had representatives
from the banking industry who looked at
loan documents
for many property transfers and did not
see
uh septic system evaluation reports in
many of those loan documents so you know
maybe in some areas and by some realtors
this is standard process but what we
learned in the commission is that it is
not universal and that there is this gap
for both buyers
municipalities and for the state agency
so in my view
hb 426 is a very very small step on a
longer path that we really need to
embark on
toward more effective regulation of
septic systems that will better protect
the state's precious water resources
from the threats of nutrient pollution
and i urge this measure
ought to pass
thank you very much for your time and
i'd be happy to answer questions
thank you for your testimony
any senior questions no question see no
questions thank you very much for your
testimony you're welcome uh
is malloy or uh the
final chance
i think he's gone
i do not
is there anyone from the audience who uh
wishes to testify who has not signed up
or anyone that i've missed
i'm sure we've got one hand raised
who's
that is uh gary abbott
uh gary abbott
are you
there
i'm sure he's coming
thank you chairman renzullo committee
members for the record again my name is
gary abbott i'm
the executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire i just want to bring forward a
couple of concerns uh
i presented this bill before both my
legislative committee and my board of
directors
they really had two
two issues and i think they were
somewhat brought up by the realtors but
i just want to go over them
the first one was the expansion from 200
feet to 250
on line five
we believe it will encompass a lot more
properties
we do believe the shoreline protection
regulations are slightly different than
septic regulations
just so the committee knows you can
place a septic system
a standard system 75 feet from your well
and so the expansion of from 200 to 250
or any property in that zone could
encumber a lot more properties that are
currently not under this regulation
that probably don't need to be under
this
the second point that the my committees
raised was line 24.
um
we're fully in support of protecting our
environment protecting our waterways and
our lakes and rivers
but line 24 compliance with the current
department requirements it really
doesn't say
failed system
uh it it leaves the door open for a lot
of
interpretation
and conflict as to what the current
regulations are and whether the success
the system
is functioning properly even though it's
an older system so it does open the door
um the the last point i think in general
was is and i don't have the answer to
this it's just
you hate to put in regulations that
encumbers a lot of properties and a lot
of regulations
uh for those few that are in the
polluting category and i think that was
a concern of whether we have any kind of
des environmental need assessment you
may have that but it was just a question
i feel that from my board of directors
that that would be helpful but we do
have two concerns that uh
ask that the committee not support the
bill if they move to the 250 feet or
clarify uh line 24. so with that i end
my testimony and answer any questions
and again thank you for the opportunity
thank you for your testimony and thank
you very much
all right
no one else
is there anyone from des
on the line or in the audience
uh stand by certain young ones
you've got rob tardif
rob cardiff
can you hear me now i'm sorry i uh oh
let me do my video too okay
okay
thank you uh sorry about that uh thank
you mr chairman members of the committee
uh for the record i am rob tardif i'm
the administrator of the subsurface
systems program within the department of
environmental services
uh for those who don't know the
subsurface systems bureau regulates all
on-site wastewater systems or septic
systems
and i along with steve kutcher were
representing the department
on the shoreline septic study commission
that recently produced the the report
that was referenced earlier
uh the department has some suggestions
on the proposed language and the bill
and i believe i could be relatively
brief
because we we essentially concur with
with uh the testimony of chris albert
and pete russell
um we believe that in
uh roman five uh section d of the
proposal that the the language regarding
that the
uh the determination be made that the
system is in compliance with all current
department requirements could be
stricken uh
literally all of the requirements may
not be applicable to do a
valid septic system of uh evaluation
uh for instance uh mr mahler's reference
to septic tanks you know that that may
not be all that necessary or applicable
to determining whether or not a system
is actually polluting
the groundwater the ground surface or
surface waters
in addition uh regarding the
the septic system evaluators as both um
chris albert and pete russell stated
uh
for their license they don't necessarily
have the knowledge
necessary to
to determine whether or not a system is
in
the seasonal high water table or the
water table
and they also don't have the ability to
formally deem a system to be in failure
for the purposes of the department of
environmental services
so we recommend also as they did
to strike evaluators
from the
proposed language
and finally in
the existing language in
45 8 39 roman 8
we are suggesting to amend that language
to say
that if during the evaluation
uh or the excite assessment and an
evaluation is required
that
only if the system is deemed to be in
failure
that the department or the town the
municipality be notified
and
the that notification as far as the
department goes could be part of
the application that we would assume
would be submitted to us to repair that
that uh
that failed system
uh
there were there were comments regarding
fiscal impacts
uh if it was
if the
documentation was provided to the
department as part of an application
that could be
uh included in our current e-permitting
database
so there would be
no additional fiscal impact to the
department
if we were to have to
receive all evaluations as
the existing language currently states
there could be somewhat of an uh fiscal
impact we would have to determine who
would receive and review these all of
these evaluations and
what we would end up doing with those
evaluations because it's been has been
stated we currently don't receive those
evaluations so we would have to find
some way to manage them if in fact all
of the evaluations were to be submitted
to the department
again uh trying to stay brief uh that's
about all we have and i'd do my best to
answer any any questions
any uh any questions by members of the
committee sure singing questions okay
no questions uh just one
one comment from the chair uh
you did there there was a memo sent to
the committee from
the des but you hadn't signed you hadn't
signed up to speak and
it would be helpful if i had known that
you were there i would have gotten you
up earlier to get information uh you
know before the committee
uh i'm sorry about that i was i was
under the impression that um
you were sent a notification that i
would be speaking to this so oh yeah
uh
it could possibly have been it isn't it
wasn't in the uh the printout system for
uh
people's speaking
forget i apologize for that but what i
can do is check with
the commissioner's office on on how that
that process is uh is
being handled so any future
testimonies from the department uh
proper notification is made
thank you very much thank you
okay
see no more questions uh
uh thank you for your testimony uh
there's no more uh no one else from the
audience i think i will
close the uh
close the hearing
on
uh house bill
florida post just raise your hand button
press representative process raise your
hand representative post you have a
question on the bill or
you have a question on something after
the bill no i'm sorry i preempted my
hand raised because it usually takes me
a couple minutes for you to see it and
it's often missed so i apologize for
that i do have a question after you
close the hearing okay i'll
thank you well one thing i have okay
there's a couple orders of business
all right this hearing is closed uh but
we are still in session uh a couple
things
uh
last
session we voted
we wanted a fiscal note on house bill
well i was informed by the
clerk of the house
that in order to request a an actual
fiscal report i have to have a vote of
the committee so this is a this so this
is what i'm going to ask
uh
our is first of all i put it before the
committee do we want a fiscal report on
house
235 which is the bill concerning small
volume wells
uh
we had heard that
i think it was removed
the third nobody is uh all right
who's who paying the motion
representative kelly representative
kelly uh
is there a second
i'll second it this is rep
smith representative smith's seconds
uh
with any discussion on this i don't
think well
i'll just say is there any discussion
any questions
if not
yes could you
could you refresh my memory um
um can you speak into your microphone
or
uh
can you refresh i didn't hear the rest
what what is it that was um
why did we need this
i can't hear you i didn't she said why
did you need it why do you why do we
need a boat
why do we need the disco
because
it was asked for by members of the
committee
uh
take a vote at the time i was informed
by the clerk that it requires a vote
by the committee
in order
i guess it's a statute according to the
uh
to the clerk of the house so i that's i
will have to comply in order to get that
fiscal re request
i understand the procedure but i don't
understand why the committee felt a
fiscal note was required
i didn't ask for it
members of the committee who asked for
it please
respond
i don't want to go getting it it turns
out that nobody really wants it
mr chair this is representative mayville
yes
um in my notes from that hearing i noted
that we asked for a fiscal note to
assess the des requirements related to
that specific bill if that helps
does that uh help
you guys use your hand up again
representative spank for a question
no no i don't think that would require a
fiscal note
this is
this is what the committee was require
requesting so but i don't under
before i vote yes or no i'd like to know
whether a fiscal note is
appropriate in this case and it doesn't
sound to me
that it is from what representative
mayville said that the question that was
in the air had anything to do with the
fiscal
uh impact on the state of new hampshire
yeah representative gold and smith both
with their hands up all right
representative gold then representative
smith
hey thank you uh and my note i said it
says
that there are costs involved
and that we asked for a fiscal note and
i haven't starred
i don't know if that helps or not
all right representative smith
d-e-s in there thank you mr chair
and their testimony uh
were not in support of the bill
and one of the reasons was because of
the
cost to
des i believe
yes i have to
it's in des testimony the reason why we
asked for the fiscal note
and i have it written down to fiscal
note exclamation point
yes in my notes i have cost to des and
to customers
for fiscal note
thank you okay
yep thank you are we uh are we ready for
a vote
is the clerk uh available
yes
okay uh representative gunski
the motion is
the health resources recreation
development committee
uh
shall the chair obtain
a
fiscal
uh fiscal note
okay thank you representative gunski
representative votes yes
gunski yes representative gould
yes
representative gold guest representative
horgan yes
representative horrigan yes
representative harb yes
representative harp yes representative
crichton
yes
representative crichton yes
representative dodge
yes
representative dodge yes
harvey bolia yes
representative healy
yes
representative healy yes representative
mayville yes
representative may village
representative post
representative post yes
representative post yes representative
smith representative smith votes yes
representative smith votes yes
representative spang
representative spangfields yes
representative spang votes yes
representative grassy representative
gracie votes yes
representative grassy votes yes
representative gottling votes yes
representative cohen yeah
representative cohen yes representative
connors
representative connors votes yes
representative connor's guest
representative vale
yes
representative vale yes representative
kelly
representative kelly yes okay
representative kelly yes representative
moran yes
representative friend zulu
no
uh representative renzulu votes no so
that's 19 gays and one no
the motion passes
i will uh
i will move forward on that uh on
another issue is
uh
ivan
we have a bill
coming up
at 3 00 3 o'clock house bill
571 which goes to
uh
was supposed to go to 5 to 5 o'clock i
have been informed that they are going
to be doing some work by on
the electronics
in this place at 4 o'clock so we have a
hard stop
at 4 o'clock
so i'm going to
move hard on getting
that
house bill 571 done within the hour so i
just want to let let folks know
uh and i will announce that to the uh to
the assembled people uh
who were there to testify on that
on that bill
if i can't even if i can't do that it
doesn't if it just we're just
overwhelmed with people wanting to speak
then i will continue the
uh
the hearing into the that uh into our
next uh
time we meet which will prob which will
be
probably march 3rd
and uh let's see
it was
representative post you had your hand up
uh you had a question or something
yes um thank you mr chairman uh uh
during the testimony when i go to put my
hand to raise after they're done
speaking there's a delay so often it
gets moved on
um
before
my hand comes up so i just wondered if
we could
pause just a little bit longer
after asking if there's questions
after asking questions or
i'm sorry after the testimony is given
and you asked if there's any questions
um just a pause to give people a chance
to hit their unmute button
um and and raise their hand
okay
is there is that the process they have
to unmute themselves they just have to
raise their hands but there is
once they punch the button there's a 10
to 15 second delay oh okay
when they punch the bike and when it
shows up on our screen okay
yeah just just remind me to not uh you
know look to
to take
yeah we'll
have a
vast
representative frightened to remind me
to slow down and take a breath
it does seem to happen when we have more
people
on doing testimony so it just that we
get some lag and that's why i turn off
my camera because i seem to get a lad
when more people come on
okay
yeah this probably is a loading up of
the system uh is there any other
questions any other business so we can
or we'll break for lunch
okay the break
break for the for lunch recess
and
be back at one o'clock
management room
yeah
is anybody there
can anybody hear me
yes i can
oh okay hi um
i've got another meeting going about
what's going on here on the other side
with committee members so but
right i just had a question
what's that
um
in the the last bit of legislation that
we did uh for house
for house bill 235 just wanted to
clarify the motion to obtain a fiscal
note was it an amendment
no we had to we had to request that it
wasn't an amendment basically he was
sending a memo to the clerk's office or
whoever uh requesting a fiscal note they
just wanted to have an affirmative vote
of the committee in order to do that
okay so it's a memo
it's basically yeah we're sending we're
sending a re it's a request okay send a
request for a fiscal note okay thank you
for that you're welcome anytime
okay
i'm going back on mute i'm gonna go get
another cup of coffee before we get
started again
okay
horizon standard time
oh
no i don't
all right i guess one question
down the road
so you have 18 panelists and attendees
right now 18 bills
follow me call the meetings order
[Music]
we're
going to be just the
business before the committee
has a hearing on house bill four four
seven
relative to
scuba equipment
the chair
recognizes representative hart
thank you mr chair and thank you members
of the committee
um i was asked to present house bill 447
by a constituent i had filed a testimony
previously with the committee
um her husband was lost and never found
deep sea diving in the caribbean
she advised me that he had rented scuba
deer when he was there but he did not
rent did not have with him his gps
um she believes that with the gps we she
could have at least found his body had
some closure if he was in distress he
could have asked for help
they never found them and to my
knowledge to this day he still hasn't
been found
i will tell you i can't answer too many
of your questions about scuba diving the
first and only time i ever scuba dived
was on my honeymoon in the caribbean in
a swimming pool
but my wife liked it so much she became
a diver and gutter paddy license uh
diving off the coast of uh portsmouth
um so i i filed this bill to try to be
to make it safer for divers i didn't
require in the bill that the
rental place
has to rent it to them i didn't require
they had to rent it if you were a diver
simply that they can offer it for rent
that it's there that if they're leasing
and renting the tanks and the other gear
they offer for lease
uh uh underwater gps i know gps
underwater isn't the best technology at
this point
but i thought anything that could help
the safety of the diver would be worth
filing i did talk to the local dive shop
in
one of the towns that i represent
atkinson new hampshire um kind of funny
because it's
i represent plasto and plaistow has no
standing body of water so there's no
chance to dive in place though since
there's no water
it's one of the two towns in the state
that doesn't have a standing body of
water
but next door in atkinson there's a dive
shop the dive shop
was not against it he thought anything
he can do to help safety of divers would
be recommended
after i filed the bill it was brought to
my attention and reviewing it that some
of the penalty provisions
um
probably were not
or shouldn't have been set forth therein
because they mentioned dates of 1973.
so i asked uh ols to prepare an
amendment i had filed that amendment
with the committee and that's amendment
0022 small h
so basically that's the story of this
bill i just would like to improve safety
of divers diving
wherever they're in a lake uh or in the
ocean
who rent equipment in new hampshire
and that's the bill and i would hope
that at the end of the presentation and
any other speakers you might have that
you would consider
ought to pass as amended
thank you mr chairman that ends my
presentation
a
question about a
question by representative gunski thank
you mr chair
thank you representative for taking my
question uh are you aware or have you
looked into section 27 or 270 chapter
270 section 31
that talks about a diverse flag his
vegan statue
and that any person engaged in scuba
diving and snorkeling shall remain 75
feet or within 75 feet of that flat
which is which is our current statute
wasn't aware of the flagging requirement
and i'm not sure that would help if the
diver is off the coast of the ocean or
in a deep lake uh say winnipesaukee
someplace in the middle of the lake and
he and he goes someplace or he gets
caught in distress
the
purpose of this of the proposed bill 447
is to help the driver the diver not only
if he's
uh lost or i hate to say deceased but if
he's in distress and needs some help
okay
thank you sir i appreciate it i'm
representing gold sir
take a question from representative
gould
yes thank you for taking my question
what was the amendment again i didn't
get the information on that
the amendment strikes
article
roman numeral one and two that says if
the offense occurred prided of number
first
1973 there is a fine if the offense
occurs on or after november 1st 1973
it's a violation so they took out the
dates of november 1973 so it simply
reads
that if you violate this you will be
guilty of a violation for each offense
about a couple of days ago or yesterday
i refiled um
some information for the committee and i
attached the amendment again to that so
you might find it representative in an
email that i sent in
and representative connors
uh representative uh congress for a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question could you just
briefly tell us what the cost of one of
these units is
and where does the unit actually report
to who is getting that gps data from the
unit that the diver has on them
well their cost can go anywhere
representative
you're off mute but we just can't hear
you
nothing
representative hub do you hear us
yeah you're coming in extremely weak
you sound like you're in an echo chamber
100 miles away
does he have a microphone he can maybe
wiggle the cord or something because it
seems that sounds like it could be the
problem if he's got a mic plugged in
yeah you might be right representing
he's checking it
do you want to sign out
harvard then sign right back in
if that might help the buffer
whoa
sure it's up to you but i think that's
the best yeah whatever you know let's
try to get it back on because
i think we got a little time with this
yeah whatever it takes to get you back
on representative heart
you just signed off you signed back on
him
here he comes
may have to restart your device
it's definitely a microphone issue
because he you can barely hear him you
still can't hear him
right
and he can call in if he's like yeah
right hard you can call in if you'd like
uh that might that might be helpful the
calling information is on the email that
was sent this morning at eight
restart your device in the meantime
the uh what was the phone number
do you have the phone number
okay
he's just trying to call
it on pressure
okay
[Music]
can you hear me now there you go welcome
back
okay
sorry for the technical difficulties
i don't know um so the question was how
much do they cost
i had
sent out with my recent email
two pages of different prices you can
get a garmin that could cost over a
thousand dollars
there is a device around two hundred
dollars a nautilus lifeline marine
rescue gps submersible dive
you attach that
and according to this company nautilus
lifeline
when
the
line is released and it goes above water
it it's picked up by ships and boats
and all boats according to nautilus has
the capability of hearing
the beep from the
machine
so you don't need a special thing they
said it's one of these
and maybe someone that dives can help me
out here but it goes on a frequency
that's picked up by all boats because
they all use that frequency
but the prices can can differ
i thought about the poor dive shops that
would have to buy it initially and then
rent it out but then i also considered
that for an uh fiscal impact they're
going to get money back in renting it
and i didn't have the bill dictate how
expensive a model they needed to do
because i don't know which ones they
like or which ones they may use if they
dive because i i would assume most of
the guys running uh dive shots dive i
just don't
so the prices can be the cheapest that i
saw was like 150 dollars
for one of these nautilus lifeline and
then i saw some that actually were like
twelve hundred dollars nine hundred
dollars
but i would leave that up to the dive
shop
thank you for taking the question
representative i'm sorry i missed the
beginning introduction i was logging in
um so is this primarily to be used in
our lakes or do we have some
um uh
does the state have some hold over the
ocean waters out to a specific mileage
that's and then i have a follow on
please
well until you it would be in both lakes
and ocean i know uh there's dive shops
out on our ocean
uh
frontage
and as i what you missed is in one of
the towns i represent
there's a dive shop there and
they
uh rent scuba gear and things so it
would be for both
but there's just for rental it's it's
not a mandate for you personally if you
have your own equipment it's just if i
walk into a dive shop
and want to rent scuba gear
i wanted the dot the actually the my
constituent wanted the dive shop to
offer me to rent the gps
i'm not forced to rent it
they're just asked to make it available
so if they rent me a scuba tank and gear
and masks and all that just say gee
are you interested in renting a gps i
have one you can rent and you
i i sort of equated it to like riding a
motorcycle with a helmet i mean this you
can sell a helmet or
you don't have to wear one so we're not
forcing anyone to use the gps just to
make it available for them if they wish
to lease it or rent it
can i have a follow-on please share mr
sherman
for a follow-up
so i guess i'm confused um i'm not quite
sure what the purpose of the gps is if
you're underwater and you can't find
your boat go to the surface and look so
is it to control the equipment so that
the dive shop can track their equipment
or is it for the protection of the
individual that might get lost from a
boat when they're on the ocean or in the
lake
the ladder if not only yeah if they
could go up to the surface they could at
least see what's going on it's uh for a
diver that may be uh caught under a rock
or something fell on him or he's in
distress under the water and he can't
get to the surface
or
if something happens to him
and he asks for help they may not get to
him right away to rescue him but at
least they'll be able uh to know about
where he is this uh nautilus lifeline
says that it works within 1.5 meters of
where you actually are
so they they could find them
so
it is for both lakes and the ocean
but it's only if you're renting
equipment from a shop in new hampshire
thank you
um
uh representative cohen for the question
representative carb thank you for taking
my question
does the bill as written
require a dive shop
to purchase a gps
for every set of scuba equipment that he
or she has
we might possibly rent out in one day
it doesn't specify uh representative
thank you for the question it it doesn't
specify how many they need to get they
just need to offer it to the diver
and i didn't have a poll i don't know
how many divers would even want to rent
it
um
you know maybe a diver says i don't need
it i'm going to kingston lake in
kingston new hampshire
i'm okay i don't need it
so i don't know how many that need to
buy
i wasn't able to the dive shops that i
talked to and i tried to contact
uh patty
that
license not licensed that certifies
divers
but i don't have any statistics about
you know how how many
tanks do they rent in a day these places
and
how many people ask them about gps's
um those statistics were not available i
just went like you would go online and
googled and tried to reach out to a
couple of the major dive organizations a
lot of them are out in california i was
calling san francisco saying can you
give me some information what do you
think about this bill i will tell you i
didn't get
responses from major dive places that i
asked but i did get a response from my
local dive shop in atkinson new
hampshire that
anything we can do to help
make it safer for divers he was okay
with
follow one question please mr
chairperson well follow
representative harv so does that mean if
the dive shop
i'm just making an arbitrary number has
scuba systems and 10 scuba systems are
rented that day
and a person comes or say that he only
buys five that the owner buys five so he
has some available but rents out ten
systems that day
if the person number six that wants to
rent a gps
doesn't have one available is the owner
now in violation of the new law
well thank you for the question i think
that's a good question in practical
application
technically i think he would be
because he's offering it
for lease but doesn't have it to give
i just don't know if it's likely that uh
woody act would that actually happen but
the the law is written or as amended by
my amendment simply says
you have to also lease that equipment
that's all it says
i wish i had more statistics to tell you
i actually have no idea how many
uh tanks does a dive shop lease in the
day
my concern was
for the safety of the diver
and it's not required
that they have it available to even
offer to him so the purpose was to make
it available
to ask a good question representative
representative dodge sir
representative dodge for a question
representative dodge
i'm that guy now thank you mr chair and
um uh question representative harb
you compared this to um
essentially similar to a helmet law
which here in new hampshire we we don't
have
now if i have this correct the dive
shops would actually
face some sort of punishment if they
don't
have these gps systems on hand
to rent out their equipment
so
regardless as to whether they actually
rent the gps or not
the dive shops are fiscally responsible
for having these units in stock
now
our motorcycle companies mandated by law
to actually sell helmets or
do you know if they do that voluntarily
as a good business practice
thank you for the question i only
brought up the helmets because as the
rider
not the leaser of motorcycles but as the
rider in new hampshire i know we don't
require it so it's at the option of the
rider if he wants to wear a helmet or
not and i know many riders my daughter
arrives she wears a helmet some people
don't but the same thing with the gps
the diver does not have to rent it the
diver does not have to use it
the bill is structured that it's just
offered to him that's all right
so like that's why i i compared the two
because it's all it's up to the freedom
of the individual
you don't have to to where buy it or
rent it if you don't want it
now according to my uh constituent
a lot of people will have
gps type equipment
but
if they are driving where they live but
if they go somewhere else we have
somebody from mass that comes up or
florida that comes up they're not going
to drag their tanks with them probably
but if they rent them in new hampshire
the constituent thought it would be
excellent if we could say
we're going to offer it to them because
she didn't want the same thing to happen
to them who are away from their home
renting equipment and didn't bring their
gps with them
thank you for the question
representative poster
representative post
thank you mr chairman and um uh
i would like to know um if this
constituent who was looking for
a gps model had gone to
a store and they said we don't carry
them and i wondered also if you know if
in talking to any of the stores that you
talked to
if they said that people asked for them
frequently
thank you for the question when i spoke
to the dive shop locally i didn't ask
him if people asked for it
i asked him
what he what's his position on the the
bill
because i wanted to know what the local
what a dive shop would say and as far as
the constituent's husband he was in the
caribbean so she doesn't know what he
was asked or told in the caribbean she
just knows when he was lost they told
her gee too bad he didn't have a gps
and
because then we could have found his
body or maybe we might have been able to
track him
he did get as one of the representatives
say he didn't get separated from his
boat boat had no idea where he went
i know the caribbean isn't new hampshire
but
i see the same thing could happen an out
of state person comes in rents equipment
goes diving
maybe doesn't have a boat maybe walks
into a lake i don't know
um
and
he doesn't have the opportunity
for for getting one of these if it's not
offered
i don't know yes
representative connors did you have your
hands up
no i did not he asked me i asked his
question earlier okay thank you thank
you
anyone else
uh
no uh
thank you very much for your testimony
representative representative post just
raised
representative post
thank you yes i'm sorry i just wanted to
do a follow-up to representative nables
but mabel's question about who will
receive the beacon and i guess i was
thinking about um if if it was um sent
out and um you know no one got to this
person would there be any legality to
that the person died
if that's directed to me uh
representative thank you for the
question
i it i don't see
if nobody catches it
it would be difficult in my opinion just
my personal opinion to hold the dive
shop responsible
on if nobody heard the beacon let's say
or the beacon didn't catch anybody
like anything if they're renting
equipment they have to make sure that
it's good equipment and it's uh
habitable marketable good for its use
i think they would be responsible if
they rented a defective
gps knowing it was defective but the
bill doesn't talk about
liability for products and product use
the bill simply talks about
offering it for lease that's all a rent
thank you
representative
representative gold for for a question
okay thank you for taking my question
again um
about the um
who would hear the signal
what if the person is way inland at a
lake are there boats close enough to
hear the signal
thank you for the question um i don't
have an answer for you on that
um i just know what i was reading uh
under the
uh
if you google nautilus lifeline marine
rescue they have an information block
underneath it and it talks about the
range
how many feet under the water does it
work
and how accurate is it and it talks
about the beacon that's sent out and who
would get it and
that's the limit of my knowledge
representatives
what i found under that one particular
gps i didn't go searching all of them so
i
that's all i can say thanks thank you
sure there are no further questions
there are no
okay there are no as there are no
further questions
thank you for your testimony
thank you mr chairman
uh is there anyone else to testify
outstanding
leon uh she's coming up oh okay
she's not being promoted to panelists
but
she's she's
off
off uh
here we are i apologize i haven't been
on this side yet of the technology
hurdle
thank you mr chair for taking uh my
commentary uh for the record i'm
representative erica leon representing
rockingham sixth and gary but i'm
speaking as an individual here
representative harp my heart breaks for
your consistent constituent and i feel
even worse that the buddy plan broke
down on on her husband's dive and that
your constituent was misled to believe
that the technology
exists
that could locate him after he was lost
on a dive and likely underwater
in preparing for this hearing i spoke
with two dive instructors one was
involved in multiple recovery efforts in
new hampshire and we did when we
discussed underwater gps technology he
wished expressed a wish for a device
that could find a submerged body but the
technology is not there
when i looked up the nautilus lifeline
product it must be activated manually on
the surface through several steps that
would be out of reach for a diver who's
suffering from the bends or another
medical emergency that is likely to
happen when they're separated from their
dive buddy and the rest of their dive
group
it is
it's a technology that i wish was
available and was accessible but i'm
afraid that hearing that they can rent a
gps that will help find them and locate
them will give divers a false sense of
security
i do want to note that many divers will
bring their core equipment their bcd
which is the buoyancy compensating
device their computers and other gear
with them what they trap when they
travel and rent the heavy and more
interchangeable tanks when they arrive
at their destination
so any diver who's using a gps system at
home would bring that with them to new
hampshire or the caribbean
as a background my husband's been a
scuba instructor for over 30 years he
taught well over a thousand students
from open water divers to dive masters
and he taught it the largest military
outfitter and has experience with
technical dives i'm also a scuba diver
but i only have a single dive after
getting my open water certification i
did not call up ocean enterprises in san
diego but i was not able to find any
information where they rented these
devices to any of their customers that
was something that was only a purchase
basis because this is this is
new technology
that may or may not help and doesn't
solve our greatest problem which is when
somebody is lost underneath the water
uh
i feel i feel terribly for this
constituent
i wish that there was a solution
but mandating a product that'll give a
false sense of security doesn't seem the
right solution to me and further i do
want to know my confusion my testimony
was all built upon the idea that this
was underwater navigation gear
because on my reading of the bill
underwater gps equipment to me said
navigation so i would suggest that if
there's the possibility and if this does
move forward um that that representative
harb um see if he can also add language
that this is a locating device and not a
navigation system because adding
navigation for um for recreational dives
with people unfamiliar with the
equipment would be even more hazardous
and quite frankly deadly
i'm willing to take any questions i've
spoken to quite a few experts in this
area so hopefully i can help
thank you
so you have no questions
no
i'm sorry
you got one represent
representative mayville
for a question
thank you for taking my question
representative leon in your um it sounds
like you've done some extensive work and
just talking to different providers and
your own expertise as a diver with a
husband who's clearly an expert
do you know of any states that mandate
equipment that a sporting merchandiser
provides
uh no i
i don't believe so i have a lot more
experience as a skydiver than i do as a
scuba diver
with that it is it is left to the
regulatory the self-regulatory agencies
like uspa or it would be patty or dan
those would be the similar scuba
industries they generally have best
practices and those are the ones that
anybody who takes part in their
insurance
has to follow in order to be covered so
this is the sort of thing that would
best come out of patty or
any of the other competing
competing self-regulatory organizations
thank you
okay any other questions no sir
do you have one uh david coyle who wants
to speak from the audience okay
this witness call thank you very much
for your testimony
thank you
chair recognizes david coyle
wishes to speak
mr coyle uh
tell us how long you wish to speak and
also identify yourself
where you live
and who you represent
and and their position on the bill
hello are you able to hear me yes yep
did you hear me yes thank you okay did
you hear me about uh
identify yourself who you represent
where you live
your position on the bill and how long
you
wish to speak
yup my name is david coyle i own aquatic
specialties in merrimack new hampshire
and
i do have some understanding of how gps
works underwater as well as what we're
using today
to be able to have a surface marker buoy
is a device that we use is more less
expensive for people to be able to have
and has come more common to be able to
have with you
the
i'm sorry
i
my name is dave i own a product
specialties and um how long's about 10
minutes i'm sorry
how long
the um
i think a surface marking buoy is a good
a way to be able to signal to the
surface you can deploy it from your
depth it's going to inflate as it goes
to the surface it's something that is
less expensive that everybody could have
to be able to use
um and because for the gps gps is use
radio waves and it works underwater very
much like satellites you need to have
three points in a
and a device there is a device that
would work under water but then you need
a transmitter a transmitter that would
have to be mounted to a boat or
something on the surface now you could
mount that to your dive flag to your
buoy but if there was something to and
eventually happen to somebody you have
an unconscious diver a missing diver
most likely they're gonna let go of that
buoy
um and then that you'd have you may be
able to get back to it from that way um
that would probably be the easiest way
to locate somebody
because the nautiluses are really
designed if you get to the surface
and originally they had it where you can
actually do a two-way radio on them but
they have taken that off um so now it's
just a beacon
um but they um it's a great device it's
a it's a good device to have and um
i can tell you that i don't have
um i can't ask say that anybody has ever
actually came in and asked for one um
usually if somebody is concerned and
wants one of these that they would
purchase themselves
to have with them
the people that do have them it gives
them a comfort a
sense of comfort while they're
on the surface if they were to get um
come to the surface and the boat wasn't
there um the way they work somebody had
asked in the lake if they would work or
in the ocean
it goes on to a ufh radio and it's going
to get picked up in a certain amount of
mileage
so if there's another boat that has a
two-way radio on it it would signal to
them and then they would be able to be
able to pick them up
in the case that you're talking about
this is underwater and i don't know if
that system would work correctly in that
case
um when we dive we use a um a diver flag
um and we do
whenever we're diving but also if we
have a couple of divers you've got a
buddy team you've got one with a flag
and the other one is an smb submersible
deployment
they can send that to the surface and
they would be able to be
found that way i think that would be a
better
answer for this instead of trying to
depend on technology something that
every diver could have and would be less
expensive the question that judd had
said is i do have 10 cents of equipment
for me to buy the device that would have
the control device on the surface and in
the water is roughly around three
thousand dollars
and that would be a big
expense for me um the nautilus um would
be less expensive but that's still two
hundred dollars timestamp
uh because i would if this bill was
passed i would not want to make sure
that i have for every one of them so
that i wouldn't be out of the
requirements
um
does anybody have any questions for me
i'll uh
let me find out are there any questions
of this witness
sir i
have one question stand by
representative harms
uh representative
uh
actually technically you cannot ask a
question
uh you are you are
you because you are you are a uh a
witness
and uh you're
the presenter of the bill so your is
only for
the only ones people the only
representatives who can ask questions
are those who are
uh sitting on the committee for the for
this hearing
uh is there anyone else uh
represent representative gunski thank
you mr chairman
uh
thank you for taking my call uh call
sorry please
my question mr coyle
i when i researched this particular
subject matter
i was told that it was common
or
it is used at times where an individual
would put a cell phone on their buoy
or they are the flag
buoy in like a waterproof
uh bag
is that something that you're familiar
with i just was looking for a little bit
more information on that you know
because with the cell phone i guess
there's gps technology within the cell
phone and certain individuals that use
that
to locate themselves or that that buoy
you could leave it on the surface and if
you're able to come to the surface and
be able to turn it on um and to be able
to set your gps um there are um some
apps that work really well
to be able to pinpoint your um place uh
we you generally use that if you find
something and you want to be able to go
back to it um you could set it as a gps
to be able to get back to it by using
your phone um making sure that you had
your phone inside a waterproof
container
so that it's able to be able to
not get destroyed
okay
thank you sir appreciate your answer
so i see no further questions
there are no further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
all right thank you
and
there is no one else wishing to
be heard on this bill
there's none no further hands no of
those erased i will close the hearing
on
house bill 447.
will put us on youtube
be back at two o'clock
so
test test test
i can hear you
we are off youtube
let's open it up back up again
we got
i had 158
two minutes
i'm sure you've got 21 pounds and 15
attendees
21 panelists and 15 attendees okay
to go
representative harp can we do a sound
check to make sure you're good
hi again can you hear me there you are
you're beautiful
is the uh is the um phone or is the uh
i got my computer computer okay no i'm
on the computer
must have jiggled that wire like my
friend chuck told me to do
all right people let's let's get this on
the road
call a meeting to order for
house bill
534 relative to municipal control of
certain frozen water bodies
uh chair recognizing representative
waltz to introduce the bill oh mr
chairman uh justice uh i just wanted to
share with you because of the open
records law that uh my daughter is now
here in the room with me and my
three-year-old they don't have school
today because of um
various issues so just an fyi i think
the chair will allow it so long as she
doesn't vote and you're stead
you got it
okay
representative walls are you there
is she coming up
let's see right there
[Music]
uh can you hear me now finally yeah i i
think you you turn your uh
camera on if possible oh i'm sorry i
thought it was oh okay all right here
you are all right thank you very much
and thank you for listening to me today
um
for the record i'm representative mary
beth walls i represent merrimack
district 23 which is the towns of beau
and dunbarton
and i'm here today bringing you this
bill actually on behalf of a constituent
by the name of sandy crystal who i know
has signed up to speak on this bill as
well
um so i want to tell you a little bit
about why this bill is before you
because it seems to be creating a great
deal of opposition
um the bill came to my attention because
there is a smallish about 50 acre pond
in my town
that is used regularly it's got a very
tight neighborhood that abuts the pond
and lately there are vehicles not
snowmobiles but other vehicles that have
taken to racing out there and it's
making it difficult for the other
members of the community to use the pond
when they're out there racing which
apparently is fairly frequent
so the request was that i would put in a
bill that could begin to address this
well recognizing that
different communities have different
needs i chose to create a local option
bill
that creates
allows the local communities to regulate
the time place and manner of the use of
frozen bodies of water and
the bill applies to
all public waters a public water is i'm
sorry the bill applies to anything 100
acres or less
and anything that is solely contained
within one town because i didn't want to
create a situation where you had dueling
towns trying to disagree over the use of
the body of water that straddled more
than one community
at 100 acres or less my intent was to
avoid all the larger bodies of water
like the lakes but just the smaller
ponds contained within communities
i also recognize that the needs of
different parts of the state are
different that in northern new hampshire
where they encourage this kind of use of
their land and their frozen bodies of
water is different than more congested
parts of the southern part of the state
where
housing is more dense people are more
closely there and use of a frozen body
by various motorized vehicles um could
really create a local problem for the
neighborhood so rather than trying
establish some sort of standard myself i
thought it more appropriate to set up a
local option
where people or each community could
decide what it's right for them and
their with respect to their frozen body
of water
um
traditionally public bodies of water
which is what this governs and public
bodies of water anything that's 10 acres
or more and there are hundreds of them
in the state the des has a list of them
traditionally they are regulated by
fish and game and by the marine patrol
and they regulate things like speed
limits and safety
but those kinds of regulations are
inadequate to address the issues that
have been brought to my attention
so this is how we came to come up with
this solution for it
um
i have the unusual advantage of having
been copied out quite a bit of the
opposition of this bill before it
reached me so i want to take a moment to
address briefly a couple of the things
that i know are coming your way
um the first group that reached out to
me that's opposing this bill is the
department of environmental services um
they said that um they were concerned
with water quality that was never a
concern of ours it was never an issue
and i'm not quite sure why that's in
their their issue
um
they also wanted to talk about that this
is inconsistent with um a long-time
statewide practice on
public bodies of water and they cite
common law as if common law prevails
here and prevents the legislature from
doing something
i'm a lawyer and i can tell you that you
learn early on in law school that common
law is case law that kind of fills in
the gaps when there's no statute but it
never prevents the legislature from
creating a statute to address an issue
legislative actions always prevail over
common law
while there is a law addressing public
waters
again there is nothing that addresses
this particular issue
the rivers management committee they
wanted the state to define permissible
uses
which is a nice idea but the reality is
is that permissible uses vary from
community to community and it really is
not one thing i think is a
one-size-fits-all for the state
the snowmobile association had a concern
that i can understand they were
concerned that it was going to create a
patchwork of what frozen bodies of water
were available for use and that when
people turn to the state bureau of maps
they would not be able to tell which one
was um required or which one was limited
and which one wasn't
to that and there are two solutions one
is i put in the bill that um a town
would need to post it so if somebody got
there they would have some idea that
that body was posted and frankly if
they're just worried about the state
bureau of land and trails not knowing
which bodies of water are limited you
could put a requirement in the bill that
any town that puts any kind of
restriction on it has to notify the
bureau of land and trails so that
they're aware of it and they can note it
on their maps
um it's very clear from the opposition
that comes up but this is not a perfect
solution
but the reality is motorized vehicles
are a problem
generally not slow snowmobiles generally
other kinds of motorized vehicles that
are out on the frozen bodies of water in
our state
by creating a local option bill
this allows the issues to be addressed
in a manner that fits with the unique
needs of each community in this state
and so that's why i created this bill
and i thank you for your time
thank you any questions by members of
the committee
you're all easy
there are no questions thank you very
much thank
uh you chair recognizes uh
captain eastman from fish and game
thank you mr chairman in the committee
uh
my department has some multiple concerns
about this uh bill
um i think you might want to speak
louder
yes uh michael eastman uh captain of
fish and game my department has multiple
issues with this bill
um obviously rsa 271 120
which is the public bodies of water law
states that these are
public places for all
people to
recreate
the concerns that we have is that it
would uh create confusion uh to the
public uh two different laws and
ordinances
from town to town
in those bodies of water
state enforcement um if uh if a town
opted in
uh to
uh have different controls on these
state bodies of water that uh state
enforcement could not enforce those
ordinances we did not enforce
town or or city ordinances
municipal law enforcement would be
responsible
putting unreasonable burden or placing
them in dangerous situations
it could be detrimental to local
economies um as well
and as well uh it would uh it is unclear
in the way the bill was written that um
if my department would be excused from
search and rescue responsibilities
on those bodies of water as well
so it's uh we have also submitted um
testimony
which is a little more in depth but i
believe that that hits all of the parts
of our
testimony in writing and we would please
ask the committee to find this expedient
to legacy
thank you
is there any question by members of the
committee
no question sir you have one question
representative post
uh representative post for a question
yes i'm sorry i didn't catch the
speaker's name
who's testifying
captain eastman from the fish and game
department
yes thank you very much um i i would
like to know
if there is a fiscal cost to you
um if this bill goes through to the fish
and game commission
thank you representative post i know of
no fiscal cost
once again
it's unclear if it would uh reduce
search and rescue responsibilities
and if this was under any municipal
control would need to be handled by that
municipality
and could not be enforced by state
enforcement
thank you very much that answers your
question
smith
representative smith for question
thank you mr chair and welcome back to
resources captain eastman nice to not
see you again i mean because we're on
zoom um
you you uh talked about rsa 271 120
about public waters and the sponsor of
the bill talked about the pub waters
held in the public trust only being part
of common law
are those two conflicting things or do
they cover two completely different
things to the best of your knowledge
um i am unsure uh if they're covering a
common law i know that um
it's rsa 271 20
that speaks about
10 acres of
area
water bodies and greater being public
bodies of water are constituted as such
um
so i i know that that is uh it is law i
don't know
the common law or otherwise
yeah
thank you
i'm sorry representative post has her
hand up again representative post for a
second question no i'm sorry that was a
mistake
okay
you know further questions
thank you captain
uh
hopefully
crystal
to speak on the speak on the issue
she is in support
and she is homework
all right
sandra crystal are you what
yes i am
okay and
the uh
again you know it's your name uh
where you're from how long you wish to
speak
uh and uh it says you are in support
sure uh so my name is sandra crystal um
i live in beau i'm representing myself
and i think it's going to be about four
or five minutes
so thank you for the opportunity to um
testify um
speak to house bill 534
i have lived in beau for almost 22 years
i live walking distance from turry pond
a 47-acre natural lake
with the fish and game boat access
toury pond is used by kayakers
and small boats as there are limits on
horsepower and speed when the pond has
opened water
in the winter a frozen turry pond hosts
snowmobile trails that cross from
town-owned conservation land to trails
across the pond i spent much time
snowshoeing cross-country skiing or just
walking the frozen pond especially the
shoreline appreciating the hab the
wildlife for its signs
and its unique vegetation of the
adjacent bargain fin habitat
characteristics that contribute to it
being designated a prime wetland under
local and state laws
in addition to the use of the pond by
snowmobiles numerous people enjoy
skating and ice fishing there during a
recent visit to the pond quite a number
of those individuals ice fishing were
young adults
the relatively quiet experience of
enjoying the pond's winter tranquility
is appreciated by all ages
in the winter of 2018 to 2019 terry pond
became a location in a motorbike racing
activities
this created a loud and to some
obtrusive situation on numerous weekend
days
this disturbed the enjoyable nature of
the typical quiet winter activities on
the pond some people who are ice fishing
left when the outdoor
quietude was disturbed by the racing
vehicles
the noise could be heard more than a
half mile away
unlike the usual snowmobile
travel which is more trail directed
there was continuous noise for the
afternoon
this motorbike activity occurred
multiple times in 2019
in the winter of
2019-2020 the pond was not solidly
frozen enough to support the motorbike
racing activity
a sunny sunday recently found people ice
fishing ice skating playing hockey
growing hot dogs and snowmobiling family
members around
i spoke with some people fishing and
recreating on the pond several
acknowledged that the noise of the
motorbike racing activities
sets up conflicts
one person said that he fishes at turri
pond because upon closer to him turkey
pond is used for racing doing due to its
long straight path
my interest in this bill is to provide a
means to share the use of the frozen
ponds and smaller lakes with some
predictability by regulating the time
place and manner of use
providing authorization to a
municipality to regulate noise-creating
activities on a pond is consistent with
municipal regulation of land uses
there is an opportunity for input of
residents who may be most affected as
well as those who prefer this describe
racing or other activities and as with
land use regulations often there are
compromises something i am familiar with
as a member of my town's planning board
for many years
each community is different and this
bill will provide municipalities with
choice i encourage you to
support hb 534
thank you chairman and committee members
i will be glad to answer any questions
thank you is there any questions by
members of the committee
sir you have uh representative
smith
representative smith for a question
uh yes thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question miss crystal um
how many when the when people are out
there on their motorbikes racing around
or do they are going are they going
around in circles or are they taking up
the whole pond
yeah usually it has been um and and
there hasn't been the activity this
winter i think once again the ice has
been kind of iffy
it's usually it's not the whole pond um
there are people who mentioned that they
have ice fished while they were
basically they create a track and they
go around and around on the track which
is what makes it different than the
snowmobiles that kind of pass through
and
and move on thank you mr chair follow-up
yes
for a follow-up thank you um about how
many would you see out there at one time
i don't know
i i didn't i didn't hang out there long
enough
to really um
you know
take stock of it but there were there
were quite a few there is a
um a parking area for the boat ramp and
the boat ramp is also behind bow high
school so there's additional parking
there for um
you know vehicles and such
thank you mr chairman and thank you miss
crystal for being here today um a couple
questions um
is it my understanding this just
happened one year
in 2019
the first year it happened was um yeah
the
2018-2019 winter
and then last winter it was
like i said the ice wasn't
um
good enough to
for that use it was really iffy in fact
i think a couple of snowmobiles went
into the went through the ice last
winter um so it it uh it it hasn't
happened
multiple years but i know
of things happening at other area ponds
um the hearing that follows this
and
so
my concern when i had brought it forward
you know who knows what the winter is
going to be like and
you know if it stays cold there will be
time for them to come this year but
um
it hasn't happened more than that one
year that was the year it started
uh
mr chairman may i do a follow-up
uh for a follow-up
uh yes so um miss crystal do you know if
there's any regulations during the
summer months for boats racing back and
forth and things like that yes there
there is a 10 10 mile per hour speed
limit and a 10 horsepower
um
limit as well and in fact uh one of the
conservation commission members had
we contacted marine patrol because uh
while the 10 horsepower was
on the books there was no sign about
that posted so we now have a sign about
that posted as well thank you very much
any other questions
sir i see no other questions all right
being no other questions
members of the committee
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you okay um
all the rest on this bill are in
opposition so i'm going to go start from
where normally i
started from the top down i'm going to
go from the bottom up because they're in
alphabetical order jason stock
from the new hampshire timberland
assault owners association
to oppose
three minutes
okay
now you're there
yeah he's happy i'm you
please unmute
basement i'm mute
okay can you hear me
uh yes we can
and can you see me
thank you thank you for again uh for the
opportunity to testify um
and uh
jason stock new hampshire timberland
owners association and uh i'm here to
testify in opposition to house bill 534
um simply because
if a water body is less than 10 acres
it's a it's a private water body
and
as the bill is written it basically
for us there's a little bit of ambiguity
because it says that municipalities can
regulate
public waters less than 100 acres and
when i spoke to some of my members they
said well
it would be cleaner if if this were to
go if this were to become law it would
certainly be cleaner to clarify that
it's really 10 between between 10 and
10 and 100 acres
we do have members that have water
bodies on their property
um
and
you know
frozen uh when they are frozen they they
may have occasion to drive drive on them
or use you know travel across them and
as we've read this it appears that um
there could be some ambiguity where a
municipality could say look
um it's less than 100 acres
and we don't feel you should have that
ability to travel across it to access
your back property so
again that was our our principal concern
on this bill and i wanted to
provide that testimony today just to
raise that point that
there is that ambiguity in there and i'd
be happy to answer any questions
any questions for mr stock
sir i see no questions
seeing no questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
joseph mullen
joseph mullen representing himself in
the congressional sportsman's foundation
opposes the bill which is to speak for
two minutes
and he's up sir hello mr mr chairman can
you hear me
uh yes i can hear you
i apologize for that my computer made me
rejoin here all right
you're you're right the floor is yours
thank you and good afternoon mr chairman
and honorable members of the committee
my name is joe mullen i'm from grafton
massachusetts i'm the northeastern
states assistant manager for the
congressional sportsman's foundation
the 501 c 3
non-profit i represent today
i would like to express my opposition to
house bill 534
i'll be submitting written testimony as
well
so to touch upon some of the high level
points with my time
um
in 2020 new hampshire's sportsmen and
women generated around 18 million
dollars for conservation through the
unique user page public benefits
structure
known as the american system of
conservation funding
this includes revenue derived from
licensed sales and taxes upon sporting
related goods
and this revenue provides the lion's
share of funds for state fish and
wildlife agencies including of the new
hampshire fish and game department
ice fishing is a time-honored tradition
uh you know i know that many of you know
enjoyed by sportsman moment throughout
all of new hampshire and by purchasing
the necessary licenses and equipment
these anglers are contributing uh
valuable much-needed dollars towards the
american system of conservation funding
last year new hampshire saw 150
000 paid
fishing license holders who spent a
total of six million dollars
on licenses with many of these
individuals being
uh taking part in ice fishing
um
should a municipality
opt to close its frozen public waters to
such opportunities it would undoubtedly
have a detrimental effect on the
department's bottom line
now i know that the department has
already mentioned its concerns with the
enforcement aspect um which i will you
know
refer to to their testimony
but i believe that calling on
enforcement uh to react to such
variations is burdensome and time
consuming as has been stated
once again i'd like to reiterate my
opposition to house bill 534 and i thank
you for your time
thank you very much
any questions
of mr mueller
i see no question sir
there being no questions
thank you very much for your testimony
now a chair calls
brian labrie
representing the new hampshire
snowmobile association
moses
and for wish to speak for three minutes
can you hear me okay
uh yeah you're still on you if you'd
like still
still on mute now if you're fine now
you're fine now okay very good good
afternoon chairman members of the house
i'll try to be as brief as i can my name
is brian labrie i serve on the board of
directors of the new hampshire
snowmobile association i appear
before the committee in opposition to
house bill
534. by way of background since its
founding in 1969 nhsa has worked with
each of the independently incorporated
local snowmobile clubs
to provide a unified voice to speak for
the sport of snowmobiling and to promote
its safe
family recreation
nhsa is comprised of all segments of
snowmobiling community including shrubs
clubs club members distributors dealers
contributors
today there are 101 local clubs 23 000
members of nhsa
nhsa has several concerns regarding the
negative impact of house bill 534
could have on the sport of snowmobiling
in new hampshire
the bill would permit municipalities to
regulate the time place and manner
of use of frozen public waters of 100
acres or less
this could lead to a patchwork of
restrictions for the snowmobilers on
frozen public waters
unless snowmobilers monitored each of
the local governing bodies in the state
they could be unaware of new
restrictions
which could be implemented at any time
snowmobiling is a major portion of
winter tourism economy
continued continual additions or
existing
excuse me continual additions or
eliminations of restrictions by local
governing bodies without coordination
and appropriate stakeholders would
hamper the existing trail network and
writers experiences across the state
additionally violations of the
restrictions would likely become common
since many frozen bodies of water do not
have a usual access point
current nh law rsa 215 c4 provides the
executive director of fish and game with
the ability to temporarily close
portions of frozen water for safety
concerns
this is a separate provision
in the same law which limits speeds on
back lake in pittsburgh between sunrise
and sunset
that statute indicates non-compliance
with requirement is a violation
since this restriction is law all
parties are aware of its existence
further the public was provided an
opportunity to support or oppose the
restriction prior to its enactment since
it went through the state legislative
process
this is more transparent and effective
manner to regulate uses of frozen bodies
water
while not all clubs
have trails that directly traverse
frozen bodies of water some clubs use
these lakes and ponds to hold annual
fundraising events
since fish and game regulates and
enforces the laws that pertain to these
areas we believe the state should
maintain jurisdiction and control
most municipal police departments simply
do not have the specific seasonal
resources
to effectively regulate snowmobiles
enforcing municipal regulations would
require winter equipment and extra
personnel that are properly trained
this is best left to the professional
state agencies that have years of
valuable experience in dealing with
these areas
if there was an issue
for a frozen for a specific frozen water
body the appropriate manner in which to
address it is to introduce legislation
that way any restrictions like those for
back lake appear in a statute and the
public can be better educated regarding
the restrictions
in addition interested stakeholders like
nhsa fish and game and bureau of trails
can assist with ensuring compliance the
public's right to use navigable waters
in new hampshire appears to be fairly
broad in fact courts have held that
public's right to use such waters is not
merely limited to navigation and fishery
but includes all the useful and lawful
purposes
we ask you to support public access and
oppose house bill 534
thank you for the opportunity to testify
thank you any uh any questions
of this celebration
sir i see no questions
there being no questions
thank you very much
the chair recognizes robert johnson
representing the new hampshire farm
bureau federation
justin johnson
are you there
he's coming off from you
mr johnson you're still on youtube
there you go
okay
you turn your
camera on
you could
here we go thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee
for the record my name is rob johnson
and i represent the new hampshire farm
bureau as the federation's policy
director
new hampshire farm bureau is a
federation of our 10 county farm bureau
organizations
representing just under two thousand
member families and just over a thousand
supporting members
and we are opposed to to the bill as
drafted we're looking at it from a
landowner perspective and i'll say that
mr stark from the timberland owners
association addressed our concern with
its confusion relative to the current
definition of public waters being 10
acres or more i'd just like to add that
you know the current law has worked well
for a number of years now by recognizing
landowner riparian rights when it comes
to small navigable
uh non-navigable bodies of water
our understanding that such rights
extend to the midpoint of the body of
water
with that i'll thank you for your time
and attention and i'll be happy to
answer any questions
any questions for
mr johnson
questions sir i see your questions there
are no questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you that is all we have on the
list is there anyone in the in the
audience who wishes to testify
okay
i chair record that recognizes
representative
gunski
mr chairman yes uh representative
natalie wells uh had a late uh
entry onto the list
uh representing merrimack 25 towns of
andover danbury salisbury warner and
webster
and she represent poster position as
opposed to this bill
so you have
captain captain dunlevy you wish to be
recognized
and he's now watching okay captain
yes mr chairman thank you
hey
i'll do my best to speak a little louder
thank you mr chair and honorable members
of the committee tim dunleavy captain
with the marine patrol
uh i had initially i forgive me i had
initially intended to uh register as
opposing this bill and and collect uh
neutral uh marine patrol in the state
police does oppose this bill
for for general purposes and concerns of
creating not only the patchwork of
different rules and laws that that have
been mentioned before me
but also the potential of a slippery
slope where the state would lose
jurisdiction uh not only in frozen
bodies of water but but what would
happen when they were open uh
and and any differences that that would
then affect boating
as many of you know
there are unique challenges that that we
face in
in trying to regulate the competing uses
of our public waters but there are
processes that that you folks as the
legislature have established through
public hearing and rulemaking
permit requirements that allow us to
regulate these different activities when
there is open water
and and for that reason i would
recommend that this be found in
expedient to legislate
uh as as it would be a dangerous
circumstance in our opinion to
yield the
the state jurisdiction uh on these
waters that we all know are held in
public trust uh and and to be used for
the greater good of all our citizens
that's all i have for you today would be
happy to answer any questions thank you
so representative smith has a question
representative smith for a question
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you uh for
taking my question captain dunleavy um
you did mention that there are processes
that processes that people could go
through or communities could go through
um
on a case-by-case basis when the waters
are open
uh such as restricting speed limits or
certain areas of lakes
is there any way this could be
put in to have also take place when the
water bodies are frozen
i i would hesitate to comment uh because
when the lake is frozen it becomes a
public way for automobiles and ohrvs
uh certainly fish and game then has
jurisdiction and and while i know they
do require permits for for fishing
derbies in various tournaments uh beyond
that when it comes to their ohrv laws
i'm i'm just not familiar and it
wouldn't be able to speak to that man
okay thank
any you uh any other questions of uh
captain ventilator
so i see no further questions
i'm sorry representing nickel
there's a bit of a lag there just a real
quick question captain ben levy that i
saw on another um testimony for you um
can you please tell me when is a body of
water considered
frozen
i'm not aware of any definition other
than the practical application of of
what uh
what frozen would mean certainly
depending on the ice thickness uh the
ability to conduct activities on it is
going to obviously be determined by that
by that uh that thickness of the
so there's no definition
not that i'm aware
thank you
any other questions of the captain
so i see no further questions
there being no further questions uh is
there again is there anyone else in the
uh audience who wishes
michael timmerster timmons
michael timmons
mike uh michael timmons
and he is now up
mr demons
mr timmons
he's still on youtube you are on mute mr
timmons
i apologize for that it's my first time
using zoom so
i apologize um yeah i'm speaking on
behalf of opposition for the house bill
number one i think to answer a couple
questions i'm actually from loudoun new
hampshire but i have a somewhat of an
affiliation with the town of beau
um considering my family grew up there
um i don't personally recreate ontario
pond besides bash fishing in the summer
mostly uh if anyone has driven up white
rock hill road which jerry pond is on
you'll see the the name timmins road up
there so we're somewhat familiar with
the area
in regards to representative wallace's
uh testimony regarding
uh
the racing that takes place i can assure
you that the users of the pond aren't
racing motorcycles they're they're out
there on ohrvs which is a per
you know perfectly
legitimate um and
legal usage of that pawn
uh
the public trust doctrine which is what
was mentioned before as the common law
that's codified in 27.20 you know kind
of dictates at the cape at the state of
new hampshire
regulates these uh
lakes and ponds 10 acres more or less um
and you know as captain dunlevy you know
mentioned earlier
uh if not regulated for the benefit of
all users and this is quote unquote in
case law
that it made advantage diminish the
value that they're derived from i
understand there's there's some concern
about the usage of these lakes and ponds
um i actually happen to uh
you know ski fish swim and all these
lakes and ponds in the state of new
hampshire regardless of the township
that they're in
hence hence why they're public waters
uh
i'm a little taken back
by
the assumption that the users are racing
racing per se you know i've been up at
lake winnipesaukee in the summer before
and seen you know 10 snowmobiles driving
across and i'm not the assumption i
don't have is that they're racing
snowmobiles across the lake
um
and you know as stewards and stewards of
the
of the lakes and ponds that new
hampshire has regulatory authority over
i think we've all worked closely with
fish and game to to to manage these
competing uses and
from a common standpoint i think that i
think fish and game is doing a fantastic
job regulating these and there is rules
and regulations already set in place
you know for these types of things so
um i appreciate you guys giving me the
opportunity to take you know for
testimony today and uh
hope you guys will vote you know
not expedient to legislate on this bill
thank you
i tell you that
oh well
any questions by members of the
committee
seeing none
no questions
david laflin
uh
the chair recognizes david leflane
mr leflame
tell me how long you plan to speak
hi thank you just a minute um i live on
turry pond
absolutely it's racing i have pictures
they come out with plows they plow race
tracks
um we're talking about many vehicles
parked on the ice trucks trailers
motorcycles it's an organization that
comes out and does racing we're not
talking about snowmobiles crossing ponds
the legislation may or may not be the
right way to address it but i just want
to be clear
this is loud this is all day long and it
is a problem it needs to get addressed
somehow whether or not again this
legislation is the right way i don't
know but um i just want to be clear
because the last speaker was saying that
this was not racing and that was an
assumption yeah this is an organized
race
and it's very loud um i'm right on the
pawn um sandy crystal is probably a
quarter mile up a hill and it's loud at
her house so it's really loud where i am
with the windows closed um and it
happened i have two dates january 27th
and february 10th in 2019 i'm looking at
the time stamp on my pictures so if that
helps that's that's what the situation's
about and that's what we're really
trying to solve
thank you very much
so representative smith has a question
representative smith for in question
thank you mr chair
um
mr leflame is there a way you could
forward a couple of photos to the
committee
sure
thank you
thank you no more questions
sorry more questions see no more
questions
and have and after having asked for the
additional if anyone else wishes to
testify i'll declare this
hearing close
and
be back at three o'clock
and i'll focus
and i'm not sure
my 20 year old
you're good sir
all right
okay are we
ready to go
all right i'm going to call the uh
before i call the meeting to order i
want to make an announcement
um so the uh
for the audience and for the uh
uh
i've made the announcement already to
the
committee i'll make it again but for the
for the record we normally the uh
this bill was uh was scheduled to go
from three
to five o'clock for five pm
uh they ignore but however there's been
a change
uh
i am up against a 4 pm hard stop
uh the
uh it has to be because
where it's there there's
technicians coming in to work on the
equipment
we have uh there have been issues with
it so
i will do the best i can to write it to
move this hearing along
i will try to make certain that uh
everyone speak
quick uh uh speak clearly
and uh and get
and keep to your time limits
please
otherwise
not everyone will get to speak and then
we will have to continue the meeting and
i don't think
that that does
the public
any good
so that being the case
open the hearing on house bill 571
repealing the prohibition against ohrv
travel on white pond road and the chair
recognizes representative walsh who will
be introduced the bill
representative walsh
he's coming up
okay
and he's up and he needs to move
representative walsh
you're
a new yourself and you're on
representative walsh
how about now
uh yeah can you put your uh
uh camera on please i'm working on that
too i
i'm i'm not the best with these things
i'm working on it
land of the blind the one-eyed man is
king
[Laughter]
ah there we go okay
sorry about that
um thank you mr chair members of the
committee
for the record my name is tom walsh uh
i'm a representative from the town of
hooksett which is merrimack uh county
district 24
and i'm starting my fifth term
um been an interesting afternoon i'll
get i'll do this very briefly mr chair
uh white road marsh some of you may know
is a man-made wildlife management area
controlled by the department of fish and
game
uh for the majority of the year it's
enjoyed by hikers and mainly waterfowl
until recently it was also enjoyed by
local families for a couple of days of a
couple of months of the winter when the
marsh is frozen
by putting some screws in the tires of
their dirt bikes
and going out and horsing around on the
ice is the way to pass the time in our
long winters
uh two years ago prohibition on ohrvs
was tucked into our budget
uh it certainly targeted these families
um and from what i've gathered it's
because one or two of the neighbors
objected to them even being there
being there enjoying one of our public
resources
there were no public hearings no ability
for discussion
no chance of solving any of the issues
if there are any just a prohibition
slipped into the budget
uh i feel that this process is wrong and
not how our house should conduct its
business
uh i also feel it's wrong actually for
one or two people
to deprive the public from enjoying one
of their own resources
i'm a firm believer that if you live
next to a public resource
uh then you need to expect you're going
to see and even hear them from time to
time
and after listening to the last hearing
which is directly related to this one
uh by their own admission we're talking
about two or three days of the year
two or three days out of 365 days
i don't know how that rises to problem
uh but nonetheless
um i'm also concerned about the
president at the sets you've heard
you've heard other things on that what's
next which pond which trail which lake
so i do know that this issue was brought
up last year as an amendment uh from
what i understand the carrying bill
wasn't actually uh looked at favorably
by the committee so it didn't go
anywhere uh of course then covert hit
and the discussions on pretty much
everything so
i decided to reintroduce the bill well
we introduced this bill
and for two simple reasons as i've
explained
uh to right the wrong of a non-germain
amendment with no public hearings add it
to an appropriation bill
and two hopefully
that we can set a precedent by the if
there are legitimate issues with the
neighbors
uh that we can solve them by talking not
simply by banning um these resources are
for everybody to use we just all use
them a little differently
that's basically why i'm doing this
i hope the committee will support this
theory
um
i'll entertain questions if you care mr
chair uh but i know you're pressed for
time and there are other people signed
up that can probably answer a lot of the
details and specifics better than i so
thank you mr chair
thank you representative
mr representative call with a question
all right representative cohen you have
a question
thank you for taking my question
representative a quick question in your
testimony you just said that the problem
that exists on hoyt pond is just two or
three days a year could you please tell
me where you got data that says on point
pond the problem is just two or three
days a year
well i didn't refer to hoyt road marsh
on this one it was a testimony on i
believe terrell pond that was said on
the last hearing they are related that's
why i brought it up maybe i shouldn't
have uh but in talking to the people
that are involved i'm hearing the same
thing uh it's ice ice permitting
and it's only a two month window and
we're looking at a couple of weekends a
year
is what i've been told i don't have any
hard data
but i perhaps some of the people that
behind me speaking will have an answer
to that question
thank you representative
thank you
all right
no other seeing no other question
uh thank you very much for your
testimony
thank you sir
would you like to go
pretty much
down the list
yes
chair recognizes captain
eastman
for your
testimony
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee uh captain michael eastman
with fish and game uh we are in favor of
the repeal this ban
um
our issues are similar to uh
to
representative walsh
on this bill
an all-out ban on ohrv's limits um not
only
trail bikes or dirt bikes out on the
pond
that are legally using the pond but it
also restricts
ice fishermen to drive out on the pond
and use
that method
with somebody who may have limited
mobility to get out
into that area to fish so therefore
you know it would
really prohibit somebody from allowing a
big getting out there to fish
if they had issues
there are no other bands on any other
bodies of water for hrv use
there are restrictions
in some but not all-out bands
once again this is a slippery slope when
we start banning certain types of use
on frozen bodies of water um in which um
you know what is next
certain bans on people ice fishing bob
houses
things of that nature so
we would ask that this ban be repealed
for a hoyt road marsh um another issue i
know that's going to be presented will
be an impact of wildlife and certainly
if we had any issue with an impact of
wildlife we would not be asking for this
repeal um any uh
reptiles or amphibians uh during the
months that is frozen
um are in hibernation at the bottom of
the pond they're not affected
per se um
by
use of ohrvs
um any
real uh
issues that
turtles and and things that issue would
have would would probably be more with
the
road
um itself and crossing the road
other wildlife certainly um there is uh
noise but we don't feel that there's a
large impact on the wildlife so
therefore we would ask for the this
committee to repeal this ban on
the use of ohrvis on hoyt road marsh
thank you
so you have one question from
representative smith representative
smith for a question
thank you mr chair and thank you again
captain eastman um
this bill uh last year as you know we
did
have a public hearing on an amendment
which was never adopted
and the that amendment had restrictions
it was opening up
hoyt road marsh to
to use by ohrvs and in particular the
motorcycles
but it had restrictions would you
support this bill being amended to have
restrictions such as
only use during the day time or certain
days of the week such as the amendment
last year
thank you representative smith i
assisted uh representative flanagan last
year and worked through some of those
restrictions um i think uh
if we were to look at restrictions that
are we better to
do those through our rule-making process
instead of putting them into law
um as we attempted to do last year but i
think that it would be better if there
were going to be restrictions to sit
down with each group and and see what uh
what would be workable for everyone i
would say operation at night a lot of
these
dirt bikes and trail bikes do not have
the appropriate lighting uh for
nighttime use so that i don't believe
that would be a concern but certainly
could be a part of the restrictions
follow up mr chair
yeah um thank you
um i know that uh i have been told by
people who live in the area that there
is now um racing around on motorcycles
um on lake wickwass and meredith and i
know that turtle pond is open to that uh
activity also
um and
do you know of other ponds where there
is a
the excitement and the fun of
motorcycles on ice is growing by year
and year year after year
i can say in the time of covid that
certainly uh there's an increase in
sales on
ohrvs trail bikes being one of them
and any outdoor use
has certainly increased so
but as far as specific um
pawns that are also being used um
i used to be uh stationed in the in the
southern section of uh the lakes region
and i know
lily pawn and guilford
you had
actually snowmobiles that would go out
and use
that for
racing i think it's a bad term but you
know certainly they did go out and then
use the pond in it in that certain uh
fashion
and also dirt bikes use it as well
i know that sand dougherty pond and
northfield also had this
from time to time
so there were you know once again these
are state bodies of water it was
permitted use um
and you know certainly
lily pond and guilford um was one that i
can think of but it was next to the
airport with
you know a shopping center across the
way and and uh around it so i you know
there weren't per se residents that were
affected by it
mr chair one final follow-up
yes
whenever there are large numbers of
people congregating whether it's on open
water
with limited access to restrooms or on
ice if there's a bunch of people
spending the afternoon
on their motorcycles or ohrvs or
whatever
there's an issue with restrooms and lack
of facilities and trash
is that something that fish and game
would be responsible for like installing
uh portalettes
we would not be responsible uh for it um
if there was going to be a set of i say
sanction if there was going to be an
event
with ohrvs attached to it um
person the people would have to get an
event permit um this event permit would
would uh
we we issued these event permits and
part of the permit is that they have to
let the
town or city for which the event is
taking place in
either be the selectmen's office the
town itself and town law enforcement
city law enforcement so if it were a
large event we would require this event
permit um but outside of that
it would be no different than
um you know ice fishermen or or anybody
else recreating on that body of water
and they would be up it would be up to
them to take care of their own
trash and such
thank you
sir you have representative kelly
representative kelly for a question
thank you mr chair thank you captain
easton for being here um my question uh
i'm pretty new to this so uh could you
just describe the general um rules
making process like how would a citizen
raise a
you know a certain
body of water a certain area as a
problem that's growing or something or
how would that process go through
so the the administrative uh rule
process uh
each year
uh or
dependent upon what uh
what section of um
fish and game uh you know division was
coming up with rules sometimes every
other year
but they would contact us
the director's office or the commission
with a proposal
there are monthly commission meetings
where they can voice issues
such as this
and then we would um
certainly there are sections of our
administrative rules for
uh different type of wildlife fisheries
uh hrvs things of that nature um and
they could you know propose that that
they that
if there's an issue that we can um
you know
take care of that issue per se um you
know for instance if it were a fisheries
type of thing it may be limiting the
number of
bass being taken on a certain body of
water something like that
and that would be no different
into the ohrv section of the
administrative rules um it would then
once that rule is proposed and as agreed
upon by the commission and the
director's office it would then go to uh
the jail car
a rule process um so that it became a a
rule within our
fis
[Music]
just a quick follow-up chair mr chairman
so just to follow up
are you aware of anyone raising this
issue with rhode marsh before this law
went into place last year
this
issue uh i know the residents around the
pond had called
the concord police department and fish
and game about the issue
um and certainly we responded multiple
times to the area where the officers
found that you know certainly any
operation of any um you know motorized
vehicle or device is going to have some
sort of a noise
um but
you know and we have rules and laws that
actually speak about the decibels that
can be um
that are allowable and you know
flash excuse me flame arresters and
things like that that need to be on the
vehicles which can you know make it
louder um so certainly our officers went
down and found no issues
they also need registrations to operate
on these bodies of water um and we found
other than
people that did not like noise
outside of that there were no
illegalities going on
out on the out on the ice
just i just want to clarify my question
if i could mr chair
all right clarification
i just just won did anyone bring it to
the rules process that you were
describing before though did any
resident you know propose a set of rules
or something that you could then act on
i am not aware of any any i'm certainly
via complaints but via phone but there
were no proposals for
restrictions on that body of water
okay thank you
sir
you have a question from representative
post
all right question from representative
post yes thank you mr chairman um yes i
wanted to know um captain eastman if um
uh
i'm sorry i just lost my train of
thought
um it was a follow-up to representative
kelly's question i'm going to have to
come back to you i'm sorry
all right
any other questions
there being no other further questions
from the members of the
committee thank you thank you captain
i'm going to
clerk
the chair calls
julie lane
member of the public in opposition
thank you sir so um when you call on me
it reroutes you to a different screen so
there's a delay i'm not sure if you're
aware of that
so thank you for your patience and thank
you to the committee for holding this
public hearing to receive input from
it
yeah you're uh speaking for four minutes
uh i'm gonna speak fast so i can get it
in okay thank you
my name is julie lane i am in a am a
taxpayer and a voter in new hampshire my
i'm a property owner whose property
directly abuts white road marsh wildlife
management area
i'm speaking in opposition to this bill
homeowners taxpayers and residents in
new hampshire deserve to enjoy peace and
quiet on their own property a reasonable
enjoyment that every citizen in new
hampshire expects
a concord resident um
you know in my
home borders the management area
we purchased property adjacent to white
road marsh so that we could enjoy
white road marsh nature you know peace
and quiet like any person in a
residential area expects
um in order to build a home near the
marsh fees are paid by homeowners
who need to comply with additional
regulations to pla um in place to
protect the marsh and fish and game has
a lot of information on their website i
will send some information and writing
to you but it comes straight from their
website
um the intent of the wildlife management
area
um it's a
they built a dam they got federal
funding
to acquire land to establish a waterfowl
habitat the intended use of the marsh
that they created was not for ohrv
racing
um not only is house bill 571
incompatible with the intended use of
this impounded area
by expecting to use the martian winter
for motorcycle racing in a residential
neighborhood it's inconsiderate to the
neighbors and landowners within a 1.5
mile radius of the edges of the
marsh many other visitors visit from in
and out of state um to look at wildlife
you know there are a lot of people who
come to the marsh to do things that
don't involve making large amounts of
noise
wildlife recreation actually um
according to a study on the fishing
wildlife fish and game website um
7.6 million user days of wildlife
recreation in new hampshire occurred in
one year in 2011. there were
630 000 people watching wildlife in new
hampshire
um what does this mean that wildlife
associated recreation contributed 556
million dollars in expenditures to new
hampshire's economy in 2011.
of this total hunters and anglers spent
275 million wildlife watchers spent 281
million dollars in addition to 112
million dollars on food and lodging in
new hampshire
motorcycles were previously driven so
loud on this marsh that it penetrated
very loudly into the home surrounding
the park the marsh and not just the ones
you know that you can see visibly from
white road
there are a lot of other homes around
the marsh that you cannot see from the
parking lot at the marsh
in 2020 several of these writers
acknowledged that they were
violating you know we've already talked
in this meeting about last year's
attempt to repeal the ban
they acknowledged they were in violation
of the speed limits and other
regulations
and it's dozens if not hundreds of
homeowners that are affected not one or
two people so
the representative sponsoring this bill
has not been completely informed about
all of the dynamics
um
it's like if you can imagine the sound
of 10 or 20 or 40 motorcycles racing for
hours on end it would be six to seven
days a week for um
about five months the reason that they
choose this pond and that this pond is
such an issue
and it's been coming up for 20 years as
an issue not just the past couple years
the reason that they want this marsh is
because it's a very shallow body of
water so that means it freezes more
quickly and stays frozen longer
so they can start racing in november and
they could go until maybe march
depending on the weather
um
in the concord monitor article published
on october 4th 2019 jim bully the mayor
who had been hearing hearing complaints
for years at that time
he said the final straw for a lot of
people was on christmas morning when
folks were up trying to celebrate with
their families and the motorcycles were
racing around the pond on that morning
um you heard testimony last year that no
one races on christmas well it's not
true
um and it's like a chainsaw on your
porch all day long
so people ignore the rules and fish and
game does not have the staff funding or
capacity to adequately enforce their
very own rules on every acre of the
state
when motorcycles were riding on the pawn
in the past years they were actually in
violation of fish and game rules
homeowners nearby called the police but
they were told to call fish and game so
they called fish and game and were told
to call the police
and they would call the mayor of concord
because they didn't know what else to do
and finally challenges with enforcement
which prevented any oversight of the
excessive noise impact on the
neighborhood keep in mind this is a
residential neighborhood completely
surrounding the marsh
the motorcycle races also endanger and
deter other visitors to the marsh so
people living in the neighborhood or who
want to visit and walk or snowshoe or or
fish even can't do that and i will tell
you this year i have seen ice fishers
out on the out of the pond i've also
seen
um a snowmobile and an ohrv
so
and they haven't you know it's one or
two people so we haven't even made a
fuss about it i've already given her
five and a half minutes
all right
thank you very much for your testimony
you've gone five and a half minutes and
that's
more than you were
saying
[Music]
representative post for a question
yes well i realized my question was for
the the last uh person who testified i'd
like to ask um
julianne if she had contacted
fish and game
um regarding uh the noise
and if so did they make her aware of the
rules process thank you
mr chair i think you have to unmute her
uh she
she's been authorized on you she's just
got it on youtube
thank you um so i did not personally
contact
the
um fishing game and discuss the rules
but it's actually in their rules already
um my
husband will be testifying more about
that specifically so i don't want to
take any more of your time
but there are rules in place already
that could be enforced
where we wouldn't even have to be having
this
issue come up every year
thank you
thank you uh
representative
donov
no questions representative
the honorable jack flanagan
to speak for two minutes in support
all right
representative flanagan
not a representative
the honorable
jack flanagan
he's upstairs
are you up
uh yes uh representative or honorable
former representative flanagan the floor
is yours two minutes
you're there
are you there
i don't hear you
sure he's coming
are you there
there we go all right go there we go uh
thank you mr chairman and members um
good to see a lot of you familiar faces
um
this uh practice of riding on hoyt pond
was
been a 40-year venture in other words
it's not something that's been going on
just recently
uh what happened was um
there was an employee of the city of
concord i think she was the
director of economic development and she
bought a piece of land near white pond
i believe she came from either
pennsylvania in new york and didn't know
that they've been riding on this pawn
like i said for 40 years
and
she complained to the various people
including the governor
of the mayor
and the mayor misspoke about notifying
everybody from
the conquered delegation and it went on
and on and on but uh long and the short
of it is um
you know this bill or this amendment or
change was slipped through the budgeting
process
uh by senator feltus
who represented concord
uh prior to his gubernatorial race
um
and the people that have been utilizing
it and have been maintaining it and then
been plowing the ice
so ice fishermen can get out there and
everything else approached me
because i'm an ohrb enthusiast
about this and and yes uh representative
smith uh and i had talked a number of
times along with uh captain eastman
about you know various uh changes
allowing them to use it but you know
trying to be adapted
um
you know i remember in the testimony
there was some concern about the
ecosystem but as as captain eastman said
is that
all the animals and so forth are under
the ice and as far as um you know
walking on the pond the merrimack valley
trail riders
have been maintaining it too
as far as i know there's no organized
races they may be running around quickly
on it but there's no organization
involved
and if someone made reference to all the
spending uh looking dealing with nature
on ohr views as of uh 2011 which is what
um almost little uh nine years ago they
did a study that there was 572 million
dollars spent on ohrv use there was 9
200 jobs
261 000 in wages and salaries
million excuse me and state local tax
revenue was 52 million
so i believe this bill basically wants
to put it back to where it was and how
it's been for the last 40 years
now
if the parties want to have a
subcommittee where you know we try to uh
work it out or with the various people
then you know that might be a applicable
thing mr chairman but you know
you know i i have empathy for the people
that don't like the sounds
but
you know they move into something in an
area and then all of a sudden they it's
not what they thought it was
and i have a real estate license and
anything outside of the home it's their
responsibility
so um i'll leave it with that and i'll
answer any questions that i can for
people i just think that it's it's not
really fair the way the process was and
the finally
is if we
don't change this you know what's next
someone doesn't like a boat on lake
winnipesaukee driving by their
10 million dollar home
and then they want to outlaw boats i
mean it's where does it end
so um
i'll leave with that and i'll answer any
question anybody might have
thank you
is there any questions of the honorable
flanagan
saying none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you i didn't need to hit
them again sorry about that
all right chair recognizes catherine
markery of the new hampshire sierra club
for two minutes
is that you signed up for it
catherine cochry
i'm i'm looking forward so i don't see
her you don't see either
the captain of the senior king
uh
i should go catherine on here you know
c-o-r-k
e-r-what
no c-o-r-k okay
uh to
someone in opposition
uh
james
stever
in opposition
first that
is he there
he's coming sir
hi i'm i'm here all right
mr stever give your name
where your town you're from
uh and
you have asked for six minutes i can
give you three minutes and that's it
and
i have to really crack down we're oh
we're only got 25 minutes left in the
year
i think so
okay my name is my name is james stever
i live in concord new hampshire
to the honorable chairman
and committee members i've been in the
butter of the hoy road marsh and a
resident of east concord since 2011. my
home was approximately one half mile
from the marsh and i have enjoyed this
natural setting in a rural part of
concord
that is until the dirt bike started
racing around it in the winter several
years ago the annoyance grew steadily
worse until two years ago when together
with the other residents in my area and
the city of concord we tried to put a
stop to it
this year it has been a pleasure to go
outside and enjoy a quiet winter day
without the annoying buzz of these
machines droning on for hours in the
background to see the skaters and the
ice fishermen safely returning to enjoy
the marsh as it was meant to be used but
like a scourge hb 571 has been proposed
to destroy the peaceful enjoyment of my
property and that of my good neighbors
once again i'm here to ask that it be
resoundingly defeated in the hope that
this threat will not become a recurring
nightmare year after year let's be clear
as to what motocross riding on a frozen
pond means based on my eye and ear
witness account
this is an unmonitored unregulated
continuously increasing number of
essentially muffler list dirt bikes with
spiked wheels driving at high speeds in
circles on ice for hours at a time
anyone who would suggest that that these
machines do not create continuous
barrage of high decibel noise
is either death or speaking in the
absence of truth
and i provided a link with a
representation of what it sounds like
for the committee members in my
testimony that i've submitted white road
marsh is a wildlife management area
whose stated primary purpose as
identified on the fish and game website
is to quote protect and improve habitat
for wildlife you don't need to you don't
need a degree in animal science to
realize that any wildlife with
auditory capabilities exposed to the
disturbances of this of these machines
which scatter
far and wide to avoid this area even
long after the machines have packed up
and left it must be concluded that
the concentrated motor crosstrack riding
terrorizes and degrades wildlife habitat
and is therefore completely
contradictory to the stated primary
purpose of this area the track area used
for motocross riding on road marsh is
entirely contained within the borders of
concord and most severely impacts
concord's residential area
most of these residents and their
representatives do not want the march
specifically targeted by this
legislation
used as a motocross track how is it that
those from out of town as well as state
representatives from out of town can
propose legislation which is not wanted
here in a fair and just world shouldn't
the representatives who believe this
sport be allowed promote a suitable
location in their own community and then
let their residents decide if it is
appropriate to do otherwise is an
infringement on the property rights of
others and what amounts to government
overreach and total disregard of new
hampshire's long-standing tradition of
respecting local control in conclusion
state representatives honorable chairman
and committee should consider the
president being set by this legislation
and the potential consequences of some
day having an unwanted disturbance
impose on their community against their
will
and that of their constituents
thank you mr steven thank you very much
you're three minutes and 15 seconds i
applaud you thank you thank you
all right
representative post
uh i'll i'll allow a question but then
from now on i'm going to cut all
questions from the
from the committee
representative
okay yes i was going to ask this uh
gentleman mr stever if he had any
conversations
with fish and game about this and
whether this is lack of oversight or
fish and game and did anyone inform you
about um being able to
make a rules committee that would help
to solve this problem
um
so
i did i did actually complain a few
times about the noise um and it just
sort of seemed like um
if you called the
concord police they would defer to fish
and game and sometimes if you called
fish and game they would kind of defer
to the concord police to me that was my
experience and then
um i don't have a decibel level
reader so i was you know maybe i should
get one i've heard that they're pretty
cheap so uh maybe that's if this starts
again maybe i'll get one and um it just
uh
i don't know i guess maybe if i complain
in the future i should meet the fish and
game officer in the parking lot and then
i can record a video of them taking a
reading of the machines but
um they're very loud
so
thank you very much
thank you very much for your testimony
uh the chair recognizes michael timmons
in support of the bill mr timmons
all right what's up
um
uh
you will you
the amount of time you've been uh yes
i'm i'm i'm here now and i apologize
there is a timeout for about three
seconds in terms of unmuting
um
my name is michael timmons i'm actually
from loudoun new hampshire
um
will you wait a minute please i'm sorry
you've asked for
uh zero minutes i'm giving you three
yep it'll be less than that um
a lot of stuff's been covered by captain
eastman i've actually lived in loudoun
new hampshire which a lot of people
don't realize that
a majority of the marsh believe it or
not the wildlife management actually
resides in loudon and the residents of
that area were given zero consideration
um i've been working diligently
diligently for the last nine years in
terms of complaints and stuff that came
in on
on corresponding with fish and game on
the concerns that were brought up about
uh the motorcycle or specifically the
ohrv used on hoyt road marsh
um i've been i've been utilizing
horrible marsh since i was a young child
i was born in the 70s
i've been there before whether it's ice
fishing or recreating on the pond
and so on and so on um i think that one
of the my main concerns here is that
primarily we weren't given any
consideration to the opposition
um when when this legislation was put in
place by
the inappropriate manner that it was
um i've had conversations with senator
feltes office
you know the day after this
legislation was passed
um and prior to that i do have hard data
correspondence which i've emailed to you
guys in terms of the amount of time the
usage and the frequency
uh this practice that we do over there
is unbelievably weather dependent
there's been years where we haven't been
there at all so i i strongly object to
prior testimony relating to
the uh the usage time and six days a
week i mean
i'm 50 years old and i go over on a
sunday afternoon with my family
um and and
i've had full support from fish and game
on this we've actually set up several
meetings with
uh the primary uh people opposing this
to no avail
um
the the the correspondence i made with
fish and game back in 2015 when this
came to a head
was actually
uh encouraged by senator bradley at the
time who was a senate majority leader
um after approval from fish and game my
correspondence was given to senator
bradley and reviewed
and determined that a lot of the
accusations were unfounded we were well
within our legal right
and no further action was necessary
we've actually made accommodations on
our you know willingly to alleviate any
pressure that people may have in terms
of us recreating on that pond um we
don't start our ohrv's until after 10
o'clock in the morning
and i can assure you 100 percent you
know given my career choices i've made
in in my life that i have a hundred
percent
respect for the resource that new
hampshire has to offer
um
it it's we're being portrayed in an
unbelievably negative light and i can
assure you that there's zero racing
happening on hoyt road marsh now do we
plow an area to ride on absolutely we do
uh snow is not our wish
you know and it
allows us to utilize our ohrv stickers
more effectively considering that
we are not allowed on snowmobile trails
and a lot of these trails are closed off
for trail bikes which is my particular
choice of ohrv
so so
a frozen body of water which becomes a
public right away in the winter
was it was a way for us to go there
there i could name off a dozen other
ponds and lakes in new hampshire that
this has been happening on
since my childhood it's not an
unfrequent event
yes i'm sorry i'm and i'll close at that
and i apologize but i have emailed you
all the correspondence with fish and
game
in 2015 that was relayed by senator
bradley
uh the current captain at the time was
captain john wimsat
and
we were well you know and again i
apologize i i had a formal
maybe testimony approved but i've
emailed you all the description of that
activation of photos
of what the typical occurrence is at
hoyt road marsh particularly thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
uh the
chair recognizes
mr
eric summers
in opposition
asked for 10 minutes you have three
mr summers are you there
exactly just has to come off nature you
have to come off mute mr summit
yeah i should be on f3 can you hear me
yep you have three minutes thank you uh
chairman uh committee members i i
submitted
last night and i hope you all got a
packet that i uh with a statement
my my testimony relates to my analysis
of the regulations it's fairly detailed
which i provided
and i actually disagree
with the testimony
um of officer eastman or or maybe not
disagree but like to supplement that by
saying i think there's a
misunderstanding
uh and there's sort of an assumption
that any frozen bottle of water over 10
acres uh allows hrvs and i've looked at
that statute and what i've submitted to
you is the regulations make it very
clear
that um it's only bodies of water as
defined under 271.20
and the state itself has provided a
publication that lists which bodies of
water those entail
and if you look on page 13 of the
des list
you will see that
marsh does not
meet the qualifications of a
um of a great pond because it was
artificially created now somebody
mentioned that earlier the fact that it
was a very shallow
body of water it was a wetland until
they put a dam in there it's very
shallow that's why it
it it freezes fast
but in fact it is not
it is not a great pond per the
definition under 271 and if you look at
the fish and game regulations 902.2
uh it talks about ohrvs
are prohibited on lands except and there
are two exceptions and one is frozen
state-owned waters as defined in
rsa27120
and it just doesn't meet that definition
so there's a there's an assumption that
this is a permitted use but by the fish
and game's own regulations it's not
uh it's been a problem for years uh is
my understanding although i have not
lived on that pond for years
in fact when we built our house
on that spot the prohibition was there
and i have spoken to fish and game and
one of the issues obviously is
enforcement
for them they are short-handed uh they
get calls i've spoken to an officer
who has said you know you you go out you
cite somebody they just come back they
ignore it you can't be everywhere at
once
so
you know again just saying that i mean
it's an enforcement issue that's one of
the reasons why
uh the concord needed to be involved
the other issue that i wanted to just
point out and it's been touched on by
others
is this is there are competing rights
and people don't have the right to ride
wherever they want and certainly
even if it's a public way
uh the ohrv statues talk about public
ways being something that you cross not
something that you uh spend time in a
concentrated area going around in
circles uh you know you're creating a
concentrated sound but it's also the
fact that this is there are other
individual rights which are
paramount in this state which involve
the right to enjoy your land and quiet
enjoyment that's something that's been
around since the inception of this state
and people have that right and so
there needs to be that recognition that
in some places you can't do this
there are 680 roughly if you look at
that list there are maybe 680 places in
the state
that meet the definition of a great pond
mr summers your time has expired
i appreciate your testimony i will ask
everyone to please review your testimony
that you're sending
like the chair recognizes
john
musick
you speak in support of the bill
you ask for no time
is that sure
some music you guys for no time
um
try to make it two minutes if you're
good
mr
mr music
are you there
is he's still he's he's up servers on
you you are on mute mr music
mr music uh yes okay i am unmuted can
you hear me now yes we can hear you
floor is yours for two minutes
thank you sir
um
yes john messick uh loudon
i've emailed the committee my testimony
i would
like to
summarize it as briefly as i can
um
one of the
documents i emailed to you was a
description of the marsh with
photographs
the marsh itself is a hundred and one
acres
located in loudon and concord
it is contained in one square mile of
public
forests
uh no houses are visible from anywhere
on them the marsh except for one
and that one person is an ohrv supporter
um another document that i emailed to
you is uh titled sound level testimony
of residence
it consists of a map
and uh with the location of homes
there are five
homes identified
uh
of people who testified last year that
the noise was excessive
it also uh in in the key lists the
distance from those homes
to
where the ohrv is operated
there are also
the locations of 11 other homes
of people
who
submitted sworn
notarized affidavits
that the sound levels were not excessive
and if i could generalize those
affidavits
they some of them are next door
neighbors of the people who have
complained
and they and in one case they
specifically identify one of the
complainers
or
they live closer to where the ice riders
operated
than the complainers
they could not hear the ice riders
inside their homes
sometimes but not always
they could hear the ice riders outside
their homes
and when they could they did not think
it was loud
so
sound levels um are subjective and they
can be influenced by emotion
um we couldn't measure sound levels at
hoyt road marsh because of the ban
so we
conducted a sound level study at turtle
town pond
and um
[Music]
and to quickly summarize that test data
uh we operated more
trail bikes there than typically
operated at white road marsh
at a half mile distance
we couldn't
measure any noise
from those bikes
at a thousand feet
they could not be detected inside the
one of the homes
as that was part of the study
and
outside that house at a thousand feet
the ohrvs were barely detectable only
two decibels louder than the background
noise
a single automobile passing a hundred
feet in front of that house
was louder than the ohrv's
optimistic
uh your time has expired
i appreciate the testimony and that i
have been looking at at some of the data
you presented
so
i'll entertain any questions
uh i have not
uh i cannot allow questions right now we
have
approximately nine minutes left to be
able to get the rest of the hearing and
before they shut the system down
thank you for your consideration sir
thank you very much for your testimony
um
i am
recognizing
suzanne pegg
in opposition
i'm sorry i cannot give you 15 minutes i
can only give you uh
two minutes thank you
suzanne pegg
yes can you hear me
yes
thank you very much that's no problem at
all um dear chairman horrible committee
members um i was actually noted
in the honorable flanagan's
testimony earlier which is actually
incorrect this is the first time i've
actually stepped up to this it's been my
husband's involvement
up to that time you do have my written
testimony i did email that to all of you
committee members
i do want to reiterate that the noise is
it's really quite horrendous when it
happens
my concern is if if the ban is lifted
we're all working from home in some way
shape or form right now
because of covert and don't know how
long that's going to continue so whether
you're schooling children or you're
having to work from home
if that kind of noise goes on i won't be
able to work from home it will be
mission impossible um i'm i am hearing
all the same testimonies i heard last
year when i was there
um i really do want you to consider just
how important this is at not just it's
her home
and um i really want to to see this
ban in place because of that and again
as colby continues and we're forced to
be here at home it could actually make
this a very uncomfortable situation if
that ban was lifted
so any questions you can always email me
back later but i just wanted to put for
the record
that i am
against this bill
and thank you thank you very much and
thank you for your uh
indulgence in the
present situation i appreciate your
testimony
uh
the next
person uh thomas levesque
from the merrimack valley trail riders
new england
uh
new england trail riders
for two minutes mr levesque
thomas levesque he's up
mr levesque
turkey's there mr levesque uh if you're
is he muted no no
mr levesque
mr levesque going once
thomas levesque
he's offering you all right
mr levesque
can you hear me
all right
i'm going to go to the next person
uh
chair recognizes joseph
bonanno in support of the bill
as for zero minutes
you've got two mr banana
on the list he's not on the list
and uh all right
spinal is not on the list uh catherine
cockery has done it and that isn't uh
you know mr levesque has done
uh
then i just have something to bring for
the record representative representative
natalie wells the bill co-sponsor
mistakenly put her position as opposed
she supports the bill
the vasquez the bank is back up sir all
right is he there let's place his hand
but and he's up on the map that i can't
handle
mr levesque
he cannot hear you
it is now on you
you are on mu is actually using two
systems
he's trying to get into
okay
is that it am i through
that's it hold it don't go away
you're fire you're fine uh you have two
minutes thank you very much um i'll try
to pull out some stuff i have submitted
uh testimony that you will have
um
and if you have the time to read i
appreciate it so my name is tom levesque
i'm in support of the bill
i was going to take four and a half
minutes or so but i think we're going to
be cut down i'm a resident of derry with
a camp and arrow i'm the president of
merrimack valley trail riders which is
an ohiv club with 600 plus
members throughout the state in
partnership with the bureau trails we
developed and maintained the multi-use
huffington everett riding area in the
town of ware and goffstown
i will skip over the the reading of 215
which i hope that you have read which
outlaws all ohr v's from the marsh that
includes the folks that want to fish
with them that want to skate or do
plowing the skating areas
continue on skip a couple of areas on or
about 2012
legislation was introduced for a similar
ban on a pawn in the town of milo and
again on lake ossipee that legislation
was rejected in committee
possibly a forecast of why the unusual
process of introducing the current ban
was taken
the prohibition we're asking to repeal
was introduced by way of the state
budget trailer bill to house bill 2 in
2019. the bill was entered by the senate
finance committee not by a formal
process of the energy and natural
resources committee which seems to be a
much more appropriate body for the
subject
burden in that 300-page document the
action was taken without public notice
or hearings
no consultation with opponents or
proponents nor the state fish and game
department which is the owner and
manager of the property
fish and game as the applicable agency
was not asked for opinion on enforcement
or opinion of the restriction to a
defined recreational segment of the
public or how that action might set a
precedent for adverse action against
other state properties
not until the bill the state budget was
approved and released to the public and
landowner to become aware of the ban
racing has been mentioned several times
i believe it's probably a perception but
no organized racing has ever
nor is intended to take place on the
marsh an organized event requires an
event permit from fish and game
that hasn't been done
as a principal of the new hampshire
public trust doctrine the state holds
and trusts all public waters including
all natural lakes
for the benefit of the people of the
state
public waters can be used for a variety
of uses boating fishing and other lawful
purposes we feel that this is a lawful
purpose
new hampshire code administrative rules
902 the use of ohrvs is allowed on
frozen state public water
i'll dump the next two pages and go to a
summary if i could the original bill to
ban ohrv's was improperly introduced
and unethically legislated
what was it should be a local
conversation has now become a state
issue
or hiv use is permitted on all new
hampshire public bodies of frozen water
except
hoyt road marsh
the activity is conducted within the
guidelines of applicable state statute
and code the equipment the ohiv is being
mr levesque
is actually
uh you've gone
over well almost almost four minutes
uh
i i think
i have i really am forced to call the uh
this hearing
just to wrap it up
so i appreciate your testimony believe
me i will read your uh
what you've
what you've presented to the committee
i'm i
i am certain all members of the
committee will read will read all
testimony
especially in this because
uh
you know
the
i don't like having to end this because
we are at a hard stop because
they're
about they'll probably want to they have
to fix the
equipment that we're
using so
uh
i apologize to the public that
has to do do it in this fashion
uh it was either that or we don't have
to have an additional hearing and uh
you know
i think we've gotten the most testimony
we can is there i do have to ask if
there's anyone from the
the uh audience who wishes to
uh say something so no one else is uh
has their hand up as there's no one else
have their hand up i i thank you for
your indulgence and i appreciate your
patience
uh
i will declare the hearing
uh adjourn
that's it you are on the nature uh yeah
well is there anything that uh any other
business that
any member looks to
you know i don't think we have any time
for anything so no members have their
hands up yep all right uh we're on view
all right thank you very much
thank you
thank you thank you
good afternoon